[Music]
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and welcome to
the pre-game
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell as you guys know if
you have watched two or more of my lives
and you do not subscribe we have beef
okay
beef before i start do not forget to
like the video and ring that
notification bell okay also guys all
super chats are going to be red we're
saving for a new sound board right now
so all super chats are going towards the
sound board and if you want the panel to
like read something that you have to say
just send a super chat and we'll read it
okay so our sponsor today is cooking
with chris cookingwithchris offers a
completely customized meal plan based on
foods you already like guys i dropped 20
pounds on this meal plan it's literally
phenomenal the only reason i re i tell
you guys about it every single show is
because i literally love this meal plan
and i use it myself
okay so now um why don't we go around
everyone say your name your age your
relationship status and where you're
from
um hi i'm shmari i'm 21 years old i am
from florida i think she asked that and
i am single
um hello my name is david das i am 22 i
am single and i am from lithuania
single or not
single
oh sorry
i'm ej i'm 23 years old
uh i'm from the west country and now i
live in north london
hi my name is yasmin i'm 22 years old
i'm from london and i'm
in a situation
hi i'm tiana i'm from the uk i'm 20 and
i'm single and my voice really hurts
um okay guys so today's topic is um
abortion
and the reason um we chose this topic
it's because of the rope versus wade
um potential
overturning in the united states
um so i know we have some people that
aren't from the u.s do you guys
understand like what exactly exactly is
happening in roe versus wade no yeah no
idea
no no
yeah yeah yeah okay so um for the people
that don't know basically um roe versus
wade
was a decision that was made i want to
say in like the 1920s maybe before that
abortion was illegal in the u.s
and in the 1920s basically the supreme
court which their job is to interpret
the constitution
and they said that the constitution says
abortion should be allowed
because um
because it's under the right to privacy
so like a woman has a right to privacy
and that's under the constitution
um the problem is
when
when the founders wrote the constitution
like abortion was illegal so it doesn't
really seem
like that actually was their intent when
they wrote the right to privacy so it
seems like that's unconstitutional and
that's what the supreme court today is
saying so they're saying when they
interpreted the
the right to privacy as
um
like
letting the letting you abortion be
legal that that was wrong that was not a
good interpretation of the constitution
so um they're considering overturning it
i forgot what it's called but they
released like a
like basically saw a document that got
leaked that said they're considering
doing this
long story short
so um what that would mean is then there
can't be a federal law
that allows abortion so all 50 state
like because right now all 50 states
have to allow abortion but that would be
gone and each state can decide for
themselves and that would probably
result in about like 15 states banning
abortion altogether or
severely restricting it is what they're
saying
um
so
why don't we go around so what do you
guys think of that
like all together
wow like so you're saying the
constitution will have to stay the same
for the rest of america's life no
lifetime no so the constitution can
change i mean yeah that's why like the
supreme court they gather and like so
basically we have three branches of
government which is the locals and then
there's state and then there's
nationwide yeah um which is like in turn
is like the supreme court and so like
each step along the way you're voting to
pick your your hierarchy in that sense
um and so
if we if me you and i we say we don't
like this
and we get enough people to rally behind
us and we can go from like the different
levels and have petitions to where it
can change if we feel that it well you
can't change the constitution that's
that has to stay the same but isn't that
what amendments are but i think i was
interpreting her question as in like
can laws like the same way like the laws
can be like overturned the laws can
change but the constitution cannot yeah
the constitution is like what america
was built on yeah but if the
constitution allows abortion then that
one shouldn't be able to change right
but they're saying so what they're
saying is that
it was closely interpreted yes they're
saying that those those judges were
wrong
okay and and i personally like i i i am
pro-choice or not pro-choice pro-life
but i i do think that it's it's a kind
of a far it's a stretch to think that
the people in 1776 when they wrote down
the right to privacy they were thinking
about a woman's right to an abortion
because it wasn't even legal then
why are they bringing it back up
like right now like why is it like i
feel like it's because it's such a big
thing now because
like why are like like um seeing if it's like um
goes against the constitution now
and that it was like falsely interpreted
like right now like what brought that
to happen in a recent event um
well there's
i
i don't know actually
their own you know what i mean they they
think that they can yeah let's like
debate this again
i don't think it's them debating i think
they wanted to make
i believe that they wanted to make
abortion
illegal
and and to do that they had to look at
the constitution and find something and
then found out that actually this could
be fun
amendments can be repealed by new
amendments yeah
my bad
so the they've been cracking down over
the past few years anyway in terms of
like the amount so in america they have
planned parenthood it's like a really
big provider for
healthcare in terms of that can be like
if you've got thrush like it doesn't
they don't just provide abortions they
provide but like any gel yeah yeah okay
um so
they yeah but they're mostly abortions
though that's like there's no but a lot
of people don't use them for abortion
like you can go there for
like say if i can't if i how you're
saying oh use birth control yeah
they like if i don't have insurance
because in america we have privatized
health care so you can go like you
they have
lower or if not like sometimes like free
health services um some people go there
because um they've had a miscarriage
like not everyone is there for an
abortion and which is why it's like
funny where like they're like pro-lifers
outside like oh like you're killing your
baby not everyone is there for that like
yeah yeah but they provide 300 000
abortions every year though so it's like
they're one of the main abortion
providers that's like going to walmart
and saying oh you only sell like you
sell like a million cokes a can like
that's not the only thing they sell no i
know but i'm saying like like the reason
that people are against planned
parenthood is because they provide three
hundred thousand abortions per year
that's why they're protesting we all go
that's one that's one of those three
hundred thousand like people they can't
make three thousand like that many
mistakes in your life i mean it's just
no but it's not just one person it's the
whole like country of
yeah but that's thought
but they also it's funny though like
they've been crap like states like texas
have been cracking down on planned
parenthood and shutting down a lot of
planned parenthoods
and that's been happening for quite a
few years so this is not something new
that's come out of nowhere like these
rights it's always been kind of like
yeah and like texas like a lot of the
kind of
states yeah they're conservative states
but i find it ironic that a provider of
birth control which lowers
pregnancy rates especially like
unplanned and unwanted pregnancies
they're cracking down on the thing which
also helps to secure that so it's like
yes they provide abortions but they also
provide protection like condoms and they
also provide other birth control like
the pill
um
yeah like injections and stuff too so
it's like well they're gonna have more
unplanned pregnancies and more people
wanting abortions if they don't have
safe access to birth control well and
that's a health care issue well i don't
think most people are against like
contraceptions but i think the issue is
the people that are against
contraception they're saying like you
shouldn't be able to take my tax dollars
to fund something i don't believe in
because there are certain like religions
that don't believe in birth
in in the u.s right like
obviously in the uk in the uk if you're
looking at from that like oh we have
access to like free to pharmacies like
we have the free free plan people we
have the free like condoms up to i think
25 i believe correctly you have like a
condom carter you go in and purchase
whatever
in us you don't get that type of access
you have to pay for everything like
obviously that's not to say that like
people don't take
precautions doing that but you have to
pay for your condos which are for when
when i went there was pretty they're not
cheap neither is the plan p bill uh and
some of the other contributions because
you have to pay for everything in the us
so i feel like that's why it could be
more like unplanned prices because most
people be like they don't want to pay
for that so they're just taking risks
type thing i think it's like a classic
like a classic like a class motivated
like thing that people in like
conservative states don't want poor
people to have access to those
health care
no i don't again it's a religious thing
so but the people the people that the
people that are very against provide
like one
i'm telling you conservatives it's not
the birth control that they want that
their most conservatives are fine with
free birth control the ones that aren't
it's a religious thing but
it's but but the the reason that planned
parenthood are conservatives aren't for
planned parenthood is because they they
literally give you 300 000 abortions per
year like that that's a [ __ ] ton of
abortion
that can be put into the society and
then
end up in a situation where they could
either be unwanted or degenerated
because of their skin tone or
any of the any of the above so you're
saying okay it's 300 000 people or
babies who are not who are aborted and
who aren't coming into the world yeah
that's probably
i think it's around 50
that actually make it out of being a
newborn baby
i think i'm not 100
like when you give birth actually
survive after by themselves in life
i'm not 100 sure but i think i heard
something along those lines even so i
think that's
true of births like fifty percent
yeah
i don't think that's it
that's a coin flip right there
okay but even so if you have 300 000
people a year
in the world
it would just bring
multiple problems additional problems to
society like what
like what i said for example bringing in
for example if all these people who
wanted abortions
don't want the child anymore that's
ended up being an adoption into care
homes what's wrong with adoption
nothing's wrong with kids
a lot of government funding but there's
not a lot of government funding within
those sectors so then they are treated
less of a human being
in because too do you think their life
is less valuable because they're poor
hell next or they're adopted hello
because that's that's what you're
insinuating i'm saying that's how
they're treated by society and they're
not like they're not being loved so yes
they're
yes adoption is good but the
practicality of it is that a lot of
people are not being adopted and a lot
of people cannot be adopted or even when
like i'm in foster care say i'm a foster
carer and let's pretend just for the
sake of document i'm 15.
um my parents died and i'm in the system
i have a four-year-old sister and a
six-year-old brother
and this is where my parents left well
no one wants to adopt us um
or like even consider fostering us
because it's like
no maybe it could be a racial thing how
she was suggesting like people may not
like me because of race or simply
because like we're a set of siblings
like oh i can't split them up but these
a lot of government in america like
anything that is government funded
is totally underfunded and it's not
going to be allocated the resources that
it would need to to make it evident that
these um
foster kids are adopted
that's not true though there's a lot of
like catholic and like christian
organizations that specifically help
with adoption right no it's not enough
to even
touch the surface yeah put it to put you
this way yeah like number number wise in
the world right there's over seven
billion people in the world right if you
look at it like this right if everyone
was so
wanted to adopt yeah they would not need
there would be no need for no childhood
no no no
again so my parents adopted like i know
a decent amount about adoption my
parents gave up a kid for adoption and
my parents they adopted three like three
of my siblings were adopted and the
issue the issue is that it's legally
it's very hard because you can't you
have to make sure that the the parents
are safe well only conservative people
can really adopt i feel in america that
you've got to be like married and be in
a secure relationship not necessarily
not necessarily it is shifting but it's
more so that you need a lot of money
which is what you're saying it's very
difficult to adopt
as well so i feel like it's unrealistic
to say that that will compensate for
those people that will be giving away
their children
50 of um women over 30 are single and
childless like there's a free there's
going to be a fertility they don't they
don't want for that some of them don't
that goes to why they're trying to like
no i'm saying marriage is getting later
and later so there's going to be
fertility issues coming in like of
course yeah but they do
it the statistics show that people who
marry later in life they have a lower
divorce rate
it's the cases the highest divorce rates
are people who married in younger ages
between 15 and 24 and then also in the
ages between like 24 and and 30. i i
heard the highest marriage
when i looked at it it was between 25
and 30 was um the highest marriage rate
so where did you get that from the
height what the highest divorce rate
yeah yeah
okay and it was like statistics i was
looking through actually after we had
our chat like i was going on like
different you might you might be i think
it's like kind of like goes hand in hand
yeah yeah yeah yeah because you're doing
divorce right you're doing marriage yeah
sorry i'm not talking about marriage
rates i'm talking about the heart oh
you're right you're right yeah yeah yeah
like people who get married
younger yeah they have they have higher
divorce rates so i think um it's maybe
not a bad thing like if you're looking
at people who are waiting to get married
but they're actually staying married
like divorce is not nice
especially if you've got kids in the mix
there like it's not a nice thing my dad
is a product of a broken home
like and he always said to us and like
luckily both my parents are still
married they've been married over 30
years like but for a lot of people
that's not the case and it's it's never
ideal and it's not a nice situation to
to have to bring kids into so
um i feel like it's a good you know if
the if the sacrifice is okay people are
getting married later in life
well most women can still have kids
going into their 30s so say if you get
married within your thirties like okay
great you can still have kids and you
actually stay ninety percent of your
eggs are gone by thirty
thirty five after thirty five it's true
they also provide their facilities to
freeze eggs right and those people who
have the money to facilitate that
option will be the people who are
considered to adopt
the one wait say that again so the
people who have the money to actually
access the
option of freezing their eggs obviously
because that is very expensive some
expensive procedures yeah a lot of me
not a lot of people do have that type of
option yeah that's what i'm saying so
the same people the same people their
eggs are the same ones that are able to
how much does it cost to give birth in
the united states
i found that that wasn't free like
yesterday i was like yeah
if you made a choice to have sex you you
should deal with the kind imagine you're
16 you don't even have money but i think
i do agree with that but i think that's
a separate one at a time one at a time
go ahead i think that's a separate issue
in america because just i i honestly i
think everything in america is [ __ ] up
but
no that's true because obviously
in america like you pay for like
everything the only thing that's right
when you go to a shop to buy a simple
drink right
you get taxed on that and then that tax
is supposed to go to your like healthy
and whatever but you go in to do
anything you can dance whatever i'm
saying just in general like um like if
you want to go um
sorry like get a dental whatever you pay
like your insurance but like you still
pay for that treatment and it's a lot of
money so giving childbirth i would
assume would be a lot of money i don't
disagree that it's expensive sure but
like again you made that choice like i'm
25
i've never gotten pregnant okay and then
do we punish the women who aren't
financially stable enough to actually
like what if you can't pay to have
better like yeah
you want to have a kid you want to have
a career
you realize what that's doing that's
like
saying that like poor people's lives are
less valuable than richmond
people have to make it because let me
finish because they're the ones you
would be aborting because those are the
ones who would be aborting more in this
scenario so it's like you're insinuating
that they're less valuable and they
deserve life less no i'm insinuating
their experience is completely different
to more wealthy people which are more
likely to be conservative right because
like someone that comes from a poor
background has to make a choice
and we're going to be like completely
financially unstable by making a choice
to give birth when i don't have the
money to pay for the birth itself right
and they get girl like that's already
like i'm gonna start right in a terrible
position so why would you put yourself
in that situation but they're not
putting themselves in that situation no
but she's gonna say that because that if
you know that you don't have the means
then you shouldn't be having sex like
scientifically it's it's it's it's not
viable to say that anyway because at the
end of the day if we are talking about
biology it's natural innate to
have sex right right but then also to
the people who are we are talking of the
lower class and don't have the access to
go get an abortion these are also the
same people or sexual health care yeah
that don't have
the
the um what's the what i'm saying
resources to prevent that from happening
like contraceptive pills like condoms or
abstinence but in abstinence isn't it an
effective um they've already shown but
this is the other thing that education
the sexual health education in england
is terrible but the sexual health
education in america is way worse and it
varies state to state overall overall
education is better what education do
you need you know if you have sex you
are going to get like you have the
option to get pregnant you know there's
con like i'm sorry
okay i went to catholic school we had no
sex ed
but it's it's just common sense well
you're a smart girl so it might seem
like common sense but i'll tell you
there's some people that really don't
really don't know stupid i'm really
clueless and if no one tells them
they'll they'll go okay you're telling
me there's 15 year olds that have no
idea you can get pregnant
i'm not gonna say get pregnant internet
today come on no no no get pregnant but
like they will think like oh like
i only need to do this on this day like
some people like oh you can't get
pregnant on your period like small like
misconceptions can get you pregnant like
if i have sex and water like some people
think certain things
that logically if you're educated you
wouldn't get to that point
but these are misconceptions that a
young person can make easily without the
right education
so
but you think so if i'm driving a car
okay
and i don't know like and i accidentally
hit someone but i didn't know i could
accidentally hit someone should i be
derived
that would be the consequence of you not
having the license yeah correct the same
consequence of them not having the
resources to
not no i'm saying the consequences if
you if you make your bed lie in it like
we have so many forms of contraception
that a lot of people can't access
not kind of if you don't have a bed to
make way where are they free
but i'm like i'm simply saying that like
or or don't have sex like i was a virgin
throughout all of high school yeah like
i went half of college like oh you grew
up with different values i feel like if
you grow up in a catholic home you maybe
you talk like absence is a good thing
and you can see there's virtue in that
and you see that that's a good thing
what if you don't grow up in that
environment you have no idea okay
abstinence could have some value it
might and you don't see celibacy as
something you want to try well then
you're just not going to think that way
that's fine you don't have to be
celibate but i'm saying like it's it's
about the consequence it's about taking
responsibility for the situation i think
accountability is like always important
but i think like to a certain degree
like
getting pregnant is i think sometimes
there's a lot of misconceptions with a
young a lot of young women and young men
have that can lead to a pregnancy if
they're not well educated or from a poor
background so i just think it's not
right to say that they should always
make their bed and lying in it because
i would say an abortion as well is not
you shirking your responsibility that's
a very grown up and mature decision for
someone to have to make it's not a nice
decision no i don't think it's an easy
decision yeah you realize when they
survey women on why they got the
abortion like or why they got pregnant
85 percent say for no reason
yeah because
85 say no reason because i don't think
they actually do want to say the reason
do you know i mean what is their
business to be actually given why okay
why do i have to tell you why i want to
get an abortion do you know what i mean
i don't feel like i should give you a
reason it's my body it's my choice 85 of
them that's why 100 i still don't even
put my religion down i went to america
and i remember filling out i remember
let me pull this up i want to make sure
i'm quoting this right i remember
filling out um i've never been in this
position where it says white american
sorry black afro-american
and something else and that was the only
options i'm never yeah do you know what
i mean so it's like when it comes down
to it i'm always gonna put other because
i don't feel like i have to tell you why
am i why do i have to tell you my race
when i'm coming into a school to get
education that's supposed to be free to
everyone i'm just supposed to give
access to everyone why should i have to
tell you why i'm going to get an
abortion no i yeah i hear what you're
saying but that's that's not how surveys
typically work like the majority of the
time people fill out the answers like i
just i just think you're saying that
because you don't like the narrative no
i don't think so
a lot of people nowadays don't feel like
they should give a reason for their
actions
90 you're telling me
[Music]
2 of the people that took the survey
thousands of people ninety two percent i
do think this is about okay it is a
survey so it's like valid but you've got
to think about it you're taking a survey
from someone who just had an abortion
think about that like are they gonna be
very receptive
they're just going to want to get you
like okay no reason let's go
they're already hormonal yeah like i
don't feel like you've got to think
about situations but this is good
i'm saying this is evidence and it's
like this is evidence right and they've
done multiple different studies on this
multiple different surveys where the
majority of the responses are no reason
and it's like when i present to you guys
evidence you're like oh don't believe
the evidence of people self-reporting
something and that they choose to be
part of that i'm certainly not believe
it i'm just saying what i don't think
the evidence it has holds
um validity in regards to
truthfulness yeah i mean self-reporting
is complete it's not objective it's
self-reporting is so subjective and also
i would like to say like a how how big
is the study but more so
who if if i chose to ask you and then
i'd say i wasn't i wasn't raped okay in
theory
sorry i wasn't great
and in theory i don't have enough money
oh it's and it's nothing to do with that
maybe i just don't want to have a kid or
maybe maybe that's my reason what the
hell is wrong with that that's selfish
because right like that's that's so
selfish why can't why do i have to
have it why do i why do i have to put
myself at risk
it's not putting you yourself at risk
but there's there's adoption you can
give up the kid but no i'm saying that
because
i think giving birth giving birth
actually
kills a lot of women especially black
women
for that but i do know that like a lot
of black women uh in america die during
childhood regardless of black women
women in general
rather than actually having an abortion
people abortion is such an easy process
even though easy in the sense of
physically emotionally and it can be
draining i understand but at the same
time it's so much more safer than the
woman actually given birth yeah but
that's my point and i'm saying that
specifically because you are a black
woman
um and i'm saying if we are in america
obviously we're in england but if we
were to be in america and your argument
is that
you're like it is
you're gonna face certain difficulties
um
by
having a baby
you would be at a higher risk in this
scenario because you are a black woman
and you're not going to be taken
seriously in the um in the medical field
yeah so
that's just yeah
10 out of every 100 000 pregnancies what
that died in childbirth no no but look
at the stats for how many black women
but that's what's recorded i'm not
saying that unless yeah i know i think
there's no stats are valid but that's
just in the us and that's not talking no
that's the uk actually
out of every 100 000. no that's actually
quite a lot yes
no because 100 000 that's actually quite
a lot i find but no but my fewer than
10. mine's like seven million guys one
at a time please one at a time please
black women in america
so what
what percent of of pregnancies do you
think end in death for black women in
america
a lot more than it should happen
and i'm not saying that as like uh to be
vain or like oh i don't want to give an
answer i'm saying that like and i feel
like in a lot of these answers your
your answers will be different as you
are a white woman in america so you
wouldn't be privy to these because
you're not going to be affected you're
not a black woman you'll never be a
black woman and
if
it just it's not going to hit the same
for you because it's not hitting your
home
it is true though because i have like
i've seen this statistic this is quite
widely no you're right it's higher it's
higher so tell them this but it's still
it's still less than one percent
but that's but that's what i'm saying
you're looking at you're looking at it
from a a country that actually has the
resources and the country that actually
well because we're talking about the us
that's where roe versus what i thought
we were talking about abortion in
general well i mean
sort of but like let's let's say us and
uk because that's that's where we're at
okay but then at the same time
and we can we couldn't because they
argue u.s and uk
are very developed countries even even
today like we have the highest stan even
people poor today of the highest
standard of living than ever in history
because the thing is like we've had um
what was it i think we had like a couple
podcasts ago and perhaps you mentioned
this um
basically in the in the uk any i think
in the uk at least um there shouldn't
really
be unplanned pregnancy type thing
because
we have we
as as bad as our nhs is we have access
to free like contraceptions so
whether like
we do go and like we have on unprotected
sex that's really like on the man and
the woman because like you know i mean
whereas like we
have like the free condom we have okay
we do have plenty pill and like
i get what you mean
but most of abortions happen quite like
like quite young it's like under 20. oh
my god so a lot of them to do with like
predatory behavior so it's not normally
the woman or the person that's going to
be carrying the baby that was in the
naive situation it's normally somebody
else that's in that person's life that
took advantage of this person
and then like to always like to expect
that level of responsibility and
accountability for someone that's
probably under 20 years old
i would say under six are you are you
sure that's the majority of abortion i
don't think i think i think the majority
of abortions happened uh under the age
of 20
and are due to predatory behavior yeah i
was like with an older person i would
say the majority of
rape and sexual assault
in what way under the age of 18 or in
what context are you talking about the
predatory thing are you talking like i'm
talking about grape or you're talking
about like
just going out i'm just i'm talking
about i'm talking every time guys one at
a time i'm talking generally that um
it's normally like a woman that's in i
feel like a naive situation i think
there's a lot of predatory behavior that
happens that leads to
an unplanned pregnancy also i'd like to
raise the point one of my friends put
this actually on facebook the other day
like she said that um she was a baby
that was born out of a condom
um uh the pill and the morning after
pill and all three of those failed and
she was still she like you know she's
still here she's thriving she's alive
obviously but um so even even with
contraception contraception is not 100
okay but effectively but you're looking
for the exception and not the rule
contraceptions per is works 99.99
of the time yeah so so that's that's
like it kind of takes away from the real
argument because you're looking for the
one-off cases and same with grape that's
that's the exception it's not the rule
but why do we why do we go okay so you
made a mistake or you were naive or you
didn't take this contraception now we're
going to punish you forever because
that's basically what you're doing when
you withhold the right to an abortion no
i think i think you weren't naive i
think you're irresponsible and i think
you could have you could have made you
could have made better choices and not
been in that situation
and and my mom was in that situation
what about
when my mom was in that situation she
was 17 she had no money she was broke
and she she did the right thing she gave
my brother greg up for adoption i see
him today he's like 30 he's got he's
married he's a software engineer it's
like how are you going to say that's not
a life but how do you think that's the
right thing yeah like why because
because i think life is intrinsically
valuable right but then that means if
that's so you believe in obviously
pro-life yeah right
what was the reason for that it's
interesting
no no because i i think conception
begins at like i think life begins at
conception right but there's also
scientific
evidence that actually shows that
actually a bunch of collective cells
don't represent the human life well why
you know when you conceive a child like
it has a unique genetic coat
so you can see what eye color it has you
can see the personality that it's going
to have you can see like all these
different genetic features that that
kid's going to have at the moment of
conception and like the brain starts to
develop develop immediately
there's brain activity in the first
place
but human a human being isn't actually a
human being until the brain is actually
developed and actually have cognitive
behavior do you know what i mean such as
crying such as um
pain okay so what about someone that's a
vegetable
like that they don't know i'm serious so
if if they need to have cognitive
behavior what about something definitely
again you're looking at the exception
and not the rule no but i'm talking
about the the academic argument so i'm
talking about like if if your argument
is that it has to have to be like full
of life they have to be able what was
the word you used
um cognitive behavior yeah cognitive
behavior if that's if that if that
determines life then what about this
being the vegetable yeah so like like is
there life not does that not count as
life of course it counts as life but
some people do say
that what is the value of a person who
is a vegetable of their life what is the
actual quality of life if that person is
a vegetable like there have been
scientific studies where people actually
do look into a
person who actually doesn't have that
activity yeah and then what does that
equal to because there's obviously a
definition for human beings and if that
doesn't match up to being human being
then what more can we say not trying to
be insensitive but i'm literally just
looking at it from the factual but i
don't think that's insensitive because a
lot of people that come out of
vegetative states um
and are not able to come back to their
their function as they were before um
they say that they would rather their
family had
because yeah they they cannot live like
how am i living if i can't do anything
for myself because obviously like as a
baby or as a as a child you have to
learn along the way but if for the rest
of my life if i have to depend on you if
i know that i have the ability and it's
taken away from me and i can never gain
it back
then i think it goes to your point of
saying like what is the proof but my
question for you pearl is if you're
valuing life at conception what are you
doing
uh postpartum to value the life or like
show that as valued because if if all of
these lives are valued
and they should be valued and i don't i
don't think that any human is less um
significant than the next one i believe
that we are all equally important but my
question is if
we are so valuable as a columbus cells
of as you are saying
and after the baby comes out what are we
doing uh or what are you doing as a not
you specifically and not your parents
because i know you're going to say that
like you know
yeah your adoption but and i'm not like
taking away from that but my point of
thing is there are so many pro-life
people that are not adopting and saying
i value life but then when the life is
here oh do you see them oh oh they're
asking for a handout they're asking for
a handout so if if i already know and
not me specifically like just in general
if i know beforehand i'm not able to
sustain this life if i'm not able to
cater to it like nurture the nurture the
baby you know instill these values that
that
you need to be able to live a life
if i cannot do any of these things then
how's the life really being valued
and did you get what i'm saying you know
what you're saying
but i'm saying like like it's just
if you ask me that question i'm gonna
say my family took in three kids that
aren't there but what about the rest of
the pro-life people because obviously
there are a lot more people you know so
many pro-life people yeah but that might
be your community but no it's small
there are so many no but i'm saying if
you look online or even like
say say the videos of people outside of
planned parenthood and it's like you
know adopt a doctor and there's nothing
wrong with adoption yes of course
adoption because we need these people to
be integrated into society and to be
loved and you know like we as people we
need the connection and we need to be
loved but the thing is if you're like
shouting oh like
this is this the bible literally says
like god is saying like if you have
colon uh your eye why are you pointing
at your brother so if you're saying you
know like oh adoption adoption but then
i'm not adopting how the hell am i
telling you what to do and i'm not
instilling that well but i'm saying
that's that's not true i'm no i'm
telling you i've been in multiple
different communities like like i'm from
illinois i lived in london i lived in
wisconsin i've been in multiple
different churches there's a lot of
people that adopt in churches that tend
to be pro-life
there's a lot of people doing really
like really great things
and and so so that's like it just seems
like you're like you're kind of
prejudiced against people that are
pro-life because that's your
interpretation but i know so many
that have adopted themselves i think
part of the problem is that
i
as someone who's pro-choice
it's exactly that i believe in a choice
if you want to be pro-life if you want
to not have an abortion you don't
believe in that whether it's for
religious or moral or just you know you
don't think you could deal with that
emotionally or the physical toll of that
that's completely fine with me like
again that's your personal choice yeah
but i do not think that anybody has the
right to sit there and dictate
what i can and cannot do with my body
especially not on the foundation of
religion like i know within texas
obviously very very religious in the
bible very christian and a lot of the
guiding principles for laws there are
based around christianity
well now you're completely infringing on
my religious rights
because you're focusing on your
it's not religion though if you're if
you had a a month old baby and you
killed it in your house
like but they're not the same thing this
is to me to me it's to me it's life to
you it is yeah other people it's not on
that right
right we can't we cannot we cannot sit
here and physically prove this is the
thing we cannot sit here we can't we
cannot physically grow
but you cannot complain the two things
they are not the same thing they are so
not the same thing so
that for me is is another is another
issue of it it's not viable outside of
the womb mm-hmm up until a certain point
i can't remember exactly how well
neither 20 years yeah
most babies aren't viable on their own
outside of the like even when they come
out they're still dependent on their
mother
to yeah but i'm saying even with the
best healthcare in the world even with
you raising it i'm saying that that
fetus is not viable in any sense of the
word it would die
um
like it's because to me it's just it's
not your body it's the baby's body
at the end of the day you made that body
from your own single cell organism right
even if you do if you do believe in not
killing life right that means i would
assume that you wouldn't believe in
contraception right because you are
killing single cell organisms through
their conception right like condoms yeah
yeah yeah you are because you're not
allowing the sperm to actually you're
killing off this right so you prevent
conception
action of conceiving right you're meant
to be technically we're not even meant
to have contraception biologically no no
i'm saying that then every time a guy
masturbates it would be an abortion so
that's what i'm saying you can't just
say this
remember what i'm saying
is a living cell and it moves and you're
saying but it doesn't have a unique dna
code okay called embryotic cells then
and when they did stem cells stem cell
um therapy or whatever it is like ivf
they put they put two cells together and
sometimes they just throw them out
yeah it's it's
yeah there's so many
ethical reasons that come down to even
embryonic cells in general when it comes
down to stem cell therapy and i don't
even know if it's
illegal
it might be illegal in the states i'm
not 100 sure i don't know if they're
doing it or not but like it might be i
think it is a legal um thing but it's
just i don't think it's always been
illegal i feel like they have been
testing out otherwise it wouldn't be
illegal as to this state so if that's
the case people wouldn't be out here
using
um anti-wrinkle injections and
steroid creams that actually have
embryonic cells
in them
i don't i'm gonna be i don't know
anything about ivf like i'm not a sat
like this is just stem cells
basically when you get like a man's
sperm salad yeah and then like grow it
in
it like outside of the body yeah
yeah
so like
concepted
fetus a potential fetus would die
because you put two together uh-huh
that's technically conception are you
talking about like in a petri dish
technically you got like let's say
you've got like 20 000 conceptions
but you only take like 10.
are we going to like fight scientists
and people doing that as well because
like life starts at conception are we
going to target those people as well
that are doing ivf like bringing life
into this world
because like i feel like
that kind of alternate views like with
what a lot of conservatives believe they
want to bring more life well i i can't
really speak on that because i i don't
understand like ivf yeah it's really
simple it's like male cell female cell
together mm-hmm outside the body outside
of the body yeah and they put it
and so so let me just understand so
you're saying it would be an abortion
like in the in the petri dish well
technically if you throw that out you
say well this is the best one and they
have a unique dna code
when you go for example like that's what
the sperm banks are for because for
example as a man right you go and let's
say for example you donate right yeah
and like stern backs are then as doctors
or whatever designers work on it like
some some sperm is used and some sperm
is you know is like not used because it
dies or something they do kind of like
separate it to wear it and if from then
on
whether a woman wants to use that or
they can do like like you said like the
peace treatise thing yeah obviously but
in some no it's not abortion because
sometimes the cell itself can't survive
or something so that's why it does it's
not a throwaway it's just it just didn't
make the you know what i mean but like
like all the eggs will be fertilized for
example and not all of them will survive
into
but technically that's conception
because both the male cells and the
female cells have joined they're just
going to put the stronger
stronger embryonic cell into the body
the rest will be thrown away
is absorption in the woman's in the
sense of perception yeah in the sexes in
the sense of conception because she
chose to go down the road of ivf so the
people that do ivf are they bad people
because they are aborting
millions of babies
and people that support ivf then are
they bad people i think i personally if
you want to do if you do ivf because i
think it's a great thing yeah i just
don't think people who are pro-life
should be saying okay cool you can't
bought a baby but if you really want to
and you're struggling have a baby but
through ivf yeah yeah
i think the thing for me is that
within all of this argument
there is also
the case
for this ban infringes even on
women who have been graped
incest
like imagine
you're graped
by your dad
you now have to carry that child imagine
the emotional toll i would sooner kill
myself like real talk i would sooner
kill myself than carry that child
but that's a lot does my life not matter
nor would i do yeah
one at a time guys one at a time don't
allow people to have that choice
but like i just that's not the kid's
fault that's not the kid's fault so
you're gonna punish me for it i'm not
punishing i don't think a kid is a
punishment because you can give it up
for adoption do you not feel like the
person's mental health or the person's
okay the person who's living already
do you think the value of that life is
important enough that we should like
respect their mental health and
prioritize that before before murder not
to mention that you're rape
your greatest
can get visitation rights to see
the child
and like how how disgusting but also we
we see this there was a very famous case
in ireland where and this was what what
helped push through allowing abortion in
ireland was there was a case of a woman
she was heavily pregnant
she wanted the child she it was planned
she had it with her husband
she then became very ill and the baby
needed to be safely medically aborted
because otherwise it was going to kill
her i can't remember if it was because
it was an ectopic pregnancy or being
like a fellow i think tubes yeah
so but i can't remember the exact thing
but just let me finish the
they
couldn't legally and they wouldn't give
her an abortion because they said no
it's illegal we will be penalized for it
the baby died she died she died
painfully of sepsis over a course of
days a completely unnecessary death so
in this case in this case here the baby
is gonna die either way and now the mum
dies too if if the baby's gonna like
most pro-lifers will say if it's the if
it's the life of the mother then save
the life of the [ __ ] yeah like
yeah but this law doesn't
repeat like again we're kind of moving
off topic because we're taught even with
grape like that's the exception it's not
the rule
it's it's not it's it's the same with
same with that like that's the exception
it's not the rule like same okay with
physical health 92 of abortions are
committed for no reason and every girl
and honestly it matches with what i've
seen i know a couple people that have
had abortions every one of them was
irresponsible they were not any
contraception none
that's crazy like and this is this is
what i've seen in in real life like i
don't know a single person that was
actually precautious and gotten abortion
it was literally just them being a
response i feel like people wouldn't
well i think the people that i know if
you're going to talk about personal
experiences
yeah people i know wouldn't have an
abortion for no reason because it's such
an uncomfortable process
it's not something you want to do
essentially yeah but there are some
girls who will just it's like a choice
you have to make so i'm saying like a
lot of people are like i'm pro-choice
but i don't think it's like a
comfortable choice i don't think it's
like i'm going to enjoy this right but
that's what i'm against
but some girls who actually just
don't care do you know what i mean like
i think that's the exception i don't
think that's the thing
every girl like i know that's had well i
know i know girls that have had like
multiple and they just kept doing the
same thing i think if you have multiple
abortions you can actually die from that
i think it does a woman i think she was
from i'm not i'm not gonna say i think
that goes into the point of like you
don't really care like what you're doing
when it comes to that aspect i'm like
okay cool if you're doing this
repeatedly now
i like pro choice yeah everything like
that but like it does come to a point
where you're being okay why do you like
why why do you keep doing this
we don't care about like what someone
else does the thing is i have a friend
like
and then the sense of um
like okay so me personally i am
pro-choice pro-life for myself but i
don't care what someone else does but as
you are all
pro-life or pro-choice sorry you're
pro-choice so you're like laissez-faire
like you know do what you want
but
if you're saying do you want why do you
care if someone is habitually doing it
because at like i personally i couldn't
care like if you want to keep doing that
that's you because again that is a
traumatic experience and especially in
america like more times than not you're
paying for that yourself like it's 500 i
don't care because it comes to a point
where it's going to have an effect on
you yeah but i think from the beginning
at
any any abortion it doesn't matter if
it's by choice or not like say medical
reasons or like you deciding that it's
not in your best interest or whatever
the case either way is going to be a
traumatic experience
no yes it is yes it is tell me how it's
going to be
no but no that's going to be mentally
like great girls girls cat hair
that's what i'm saying and then if
you're going to talk about the physical
aspect of it abortion is perfectly safe
so i didn't say it wasn't safe i just
said that it was traumatic but sometimes
it's not no it's not traumatic on the
body
so it has no effect on your body it has
no effect i'm not saying it doesn't
happen the effect you say it's traumatic
traumatic is up here it's not there
unless you don't care about it
physically
it's as safe as a penicillin shot
correct that's what it says
when i'm saying some people some women
actually take a mental and emotional
attachment to the abortion that's when
it's traumatic there's some girls out
there who just don't care and will have
an abortion not saying that they can't
have it but we'll have an abortion and
continue to do that to the point where
i'm like okay
how actually how are you as a how are
you like are you okay like if you keep
doing this and you think it's like you
keep getting pregnant have an abortion
getting pregnant having an abortion
getting pregnant have an abortion i
don't even know how many times people
have done it individually but i'm just
saying like it comes down to the health
of the mother when it when it
it's gonna have an effect of you on you
whether or not you let it after multiple
times can i just make a point real quick
um i've had so in that situation i'll
agree with you only because i have one
friend female friend right who's had um
i think about
i don't want to say like about five
abortions more or less so
with
twice
no sorry three times with the same guy
um and then twice with two others but
like
in like a safe relationship they've been
dating for like a couple years right
so
obviously at first i was like i'm like
you know when she sprung it on me like
the first couple of times it was fine
but then after a while i'll i will agree
with you then it was kind of like after
like the fourth and final like what the
[ __ ] are you doing it's kind of about
adaptive behavior like but the thing is
if you're looking at it from uh for
from the first guy's time right like
it's obviously if you're looking from a
guys that like obviously
in in a sense of like let's say they did
it they had the girl gets pregnant and
she has an abortion right but let's say
if you're looking from a guy's
perspective right the guy wants to keep
her because the guy because her
boyfriend wanted to keep the baby but
all three times that he had it that she
had a shining abortion in that sense
would you say that abortion's wrong from
like oh it's at the end of the day is
the girl's choice to make get abortion
because it's her body and whatever but
like if she might not want to keep and
he had a discussion right but he wants
to do you think that that would like
affect them yeah like
do you think the guy has like at the end
of the day does the guy have a say in it
uh as much as like i said the other day
she gave my talk about it agreed to her
but then she does it anyways you know i
mean because at the end of the day all
she needs to go to do to the clinic and
be like oh i like an abortion please
yeah nowadays okay cool do they do it i
mean he can put it say at the end of the
day
because he has an emotional there's an
emotional like element that he's gonna
play exactly because that's potentially
your potential
child to be you know what i'm talking
about to me to me you can voice an
opinion in the same way about like
uh i raise the point of things like body
hair okay obviously these are vastly
different issues okay
miles apart but um
but you can have an opinion
you can express a preference
doesn't mean i have to listen to it and
i probably like like that's more yeah to
me it's like if you if if a guy if say
if guy has no
yeah after the first abortion and the
second abortion you're like okay she
doesn't value my opinion but even
but then why do you keep nutting in
someone that you know like if you know
like
why do you keep doing that is it all
roots back in knowing going into
everything that you do with intention if
you know one that you can be pregnant by
doing this and two if if you're
habitually like if i keep getting an
abortion and we're together and you want
the baby obviously go one stop having
sex with me and two have sex with
someone that wants to have a baby don't
just be having sex with anyone i mean in
their defense they were together for
like
seven years i mean i don't care about
living
yet in this in in this instance and it
sounds like the guy wants to have a baby
anyway do you guys since men have no say
and if a woman gets an abortion do you
think and so since sorry let me phrase
this better since men men have no say in
if a woman gets an abortion right would
you guys agree that that's fair
yeah it is the fairest thing you have
the final they don't yeah right so at
the end of the day if a man has no i
want this kid like i want you to carry
this kid and she says
she has the choice yeah yeah like she
gets the i just wanna i'm gonna lead
into something so just yes or no okay
yeah yeah oh no they they
they don't have a say and especially
because if if okay if you if you want to
have this kid great you can carry it
right okay so this is so mencal right
that's fine
okay so we're on the same page do you
think that men should be able to sign
off on financial responsibility because
because women get a choice of whether or
not they get to be a mother so do you
think men should get a choice on whether
or not they should be a father in the
name of like equality
that's a difficult question
it's really not a difficult question i
think in the sake of
it
here's the thing
let's just all go back to sex
know who you're having sex with for one
and two stop stop nutting in people and
saying oh like oh like
that's just science that is science you
know you already know it's the same
thing with women like stop letting these
guys not in you yeah you get the you get
the final you're we're in control of sex
yes
i think both people are if it's
consensual sex then we're both having
men will never be able to have sex if a
woman says no otherwise it's called
grape that's that's the final thing you
have to fight it goes both ways
but it still happens rather it's it
rather
than not
if it happens both ways then why do men
when men come to the court and be like
yeah i got graped yeah nothing's been
done about it but i wouldn't because
everyone's because then women
will look at the other man
being a [ __ ] why are you acting like
that
i know it don't work like that i think
that's terrible that happens but i feel
like it should go both ways it should
consent to be mutual so then so do you
think then in the name of equality again
so it's equal both people should get the
choice of whether or not they get to be
parents so if at the point the baby is
conceived right the dad can either say
yes i want to be a parent or no i don't
want to be a parent the same way women
get to just start having sex contracts
at that point no no sure i'm not sure
what i'm just saying would you say that
would you say no
so okay can you repeat the question
honestly okay so women get the choice of
whether or not they want to be a mother
yeah so they get to say yes i'm carrying
this determiner no
okay can men get the choice of whether
or not they can be a father so they can
sign off financial rights yet like
before it's born
i don't know that's a different i think
i think it's the case and i'm only
saying that is because it's like who who
am i to say that but then again i
honestly think it takes two to tango
like it's not just right it's not so
then shouldn't they both get a say
yes but you're having to say that's why
that's why i made a joke like okay let's
just have a sex contract at this point
because if you're both going into sex
knowing and this is a consensual thing
because i'm i'm not talking about grape
i'm talking about consensual sex but
both parties are are saying yes we want
to have sex so they're both equally
participating you can't just look at one
and say oh it's you oh it's you no
babies both of us because we both
decided to lay here knowing what could
come about i'm just asking you a
question yes or no yeah so i'm just
saying like like the the root of the law
in that the law is not going to be case
to case so i'm asking like yes or no we
could can men get the same right to not
be a parent as women then i would say no
no no because look
put the put the [ __ ] on the other foot
right let's say the woman wants to have
the kid right and the guy doesn't want
to but they they have it anyways right
and the kid the woman at the end
keeps the kid right and the kid is born
and everything like that now the father
has to pay child let's say they don't
want to he doesn't want it and he wants
to he wants he has to now by law that's
been in state by the country
and the world has to pay for that child
until he's 18. right right how is that
how how does that you know i didn't
ejaculate in myself
yeah but that's when you get women
trying to trap men like drake i think
that is
that but that goes along the lines of
like sticking and stuff because that
that is that is not even sex because
they had consensual sex and after
after that she went in the garbage
to retrieve
it yeah this girl that uh drake had sex
with she took the condom out but he has
a saying where he puts hot sauce in the
condom so she like tried to see there's
entire reddit threads from women talking
about how they're trying to trap their
boyfriend
i think that is the exception like i
like because that is not that's not
happening during sex that is after sex
if you're saying that you are taking a
condom after i've discarded it so that
means like the interaction has ended but
i'm also talking about women that tell
their boyfriends they have an iud or
something
that's 99.99 effective and they don't
so what i'm saying is like now women
have all the rights and men have no say
so like like it's just interesting
because like where's the equality so i
would actually argue i think we already
see that there are a lot of guys who lit
who who not legally but they basically
tick that box and say i don't want to be
involved in this kid live so i'm not bi
i would say it takes two to tango right
for sure it does take two to tango
however i would say if you don't want to
have if you don't want to be in your
kid's life
tell me that say if i say if we say if
we get pregnant okay and i choose to
keep the child you don't want to have
the kid and you're like i don't want to
be in his life great tell me that now
you'll never have visitation rights you
won't have any of that if you don't want
to be a father
fine but you don't get to have any of
the privileges of being a father that's
fine by me so you're supposed to but
one but you're like one in a million
saying that though because a lot of the
girls still have a lot of girls still
trying you know
basically no no not trapped in such a
way i can see like i see i think if we
break down one consensual sex is yeah i
think that just needs to like take place
because it's there's no way there's no
way if if we're talking about
responsibility there's no way that we
can keep missing the mark of
two people a male and a female having
sex could end in a baby like it's just
so if you know this and then your whole
point is like you know that this can
happen right then it's everyone like
you can't look at just me and i can't
look at just you like we both are going
into the situation knowing what could
come right and so that's but it's
interesting because i bring this up
later like i bring up the men and
everyone's response is oh well you you
stuck you're
in it right no no no not exactly i mean
i said that like but in
but earlier when i was talking and i
said okay well why don't you like and
i'm saying as a woman like you should be
selective in who you're sleeping with
and you should know this type of stuff
like everyone's first response was oh
but she could be from a poor area oh but
she doesn't know like like men and women
have such a double standard i said no
from the jump when you asked that
question i said no from the game i still
think it's quite complex like i wouldn't
know what to answer this question no i'm
just it's an observation when i was
talking to you like now right about
men um
like like
get signing away their rights right and
having that choice like the the
immediate response is well you should
know who you're like sleeping with da da
da da right and earlier when i say women
like they they should be selected they
should know who they're sleeping with
saying the same thing that you guys were
saying about men the immediate response
is oh well she could be poor she could
be have from a low-income household she
could be this she could be that like
it's like we always make excuses for
women but never for men we agree on that
point in regards to how what you just
observed yeah like um when it came down
when it comes down to it in my opinion i
feel like um
both know that if having sex unprotected
obviously will lead to consequences of
getting pregnant but at the end of the
day i still regardless of what who has
what say the woman still has the choice
of whether or not she wants to have the
kids okay and he should know that's a
consequence right yeah would you i can't
remember did you say you would support
men being able to sign up
i mean it depends if there's something
along what um
well damn ej aj said 100 was it
different than what i said because what
you said sounded like what i said i
think he said that if he didn't want
explain what he said yeah so so i said
if you don't want to have a child with
me i feel pregnant and i have that child
then
be upfront about that but you don't get
any rights as a as a you won't be in
that child's life so that's that's what
i was saying so if he says that like
let's say three months in right she says
i'm having the kid he says i don't want
you to have it i want you to get an
abortion she says no he can sign away
all financial rights so he he will never
be liable for child support he'll never
have any rights to the kids he can sign
off his everything to be a father you'd
support that yeah because i think then
that's your that's your decision as a
woman then to go okay knowing this do i
still want to have this child is it
still actually financially via like can
i financially do my position at the
moment right okay if i felt pregnant
today i'm not enough i'm not financially
stable i'm not in a stable relationship
like i'm single
i would
never
bring a child
into that right now because so i i grew
up working class okay and i
think that
the the so like when you were talking
earlier about you know you're saying
that poor women shouldn't have uh should
shouldn't have the kids or like them
having access to the to an abortion i
was i was saying that that um
what i was saying earlier was that like
the way you guys were talking it sounded
like poor people should be aborted
because of their financial
so it's absolutely not like they're like
because they're poor they're absolutely
not less valuable but it's the fact that
poor people are actually no just
literally viewed as less valuable
within our society
uh look at the way we cannot be
shot on by the tories like they don't
care at all and we see that in the way
that they're
concerned
they're very very happy for the people
accessing food banks rising year on year
on year in the past 10 years of their
their rule so we see that like i
physically right now i wouldn't be able
to financially support a child okay so
for me it's not an option like
financially it's not an option to have a
child even though like i want to have
kids right i do want to have kids right
but i know what i want to bring that
child into and so for me it's like okay
if i had everything there if i had that
relationship um then for me it's a case
of well now it's the fact that i'm in
poverty that i can't have this child to
me that just speaks volumes about the
fact that there's not enough support for
people who are poor to have these
children because otherwise you wouldn't
have people who are in poverty going i i
need to have this abortion because i
can't financially but support it but i
would have it if that wasn't the case
that to me is the sadness like that is a
really really sad
fact but it's a fact that is a that is a
fact of the way our world works and so
that is a really big case why for me i
think if you are like for me that that's
a really big reason why i don't care
what your reasons are for you having an
abortion and i don't care if it's a case
of if you're poor because i understand
that i know that right that's my truth
too
[Music]
so i empathize with that and for me it's
not a case of poor people shouldn't have
kids it's not a case of
yeah
that's what it would be
no but it but it's just a fact it's just
the fact that like i can't support that
child myself and then in that situation
you go okay well you could put them up
for foster care you could have them put
into adoption
i will say that a lot of my friends i
grew up in a very poor
quite poor town
and a lot of my friends grew up below
the poverty line i'm talking on like
their family surviving on a pound a day
very very like the lowest of abject
poverty i knew a lot of people who were
in the foster system who were in the
care system and they were abused their
entire time through it they had an awful
time loads of those friends became drug
addicts or died
quite a few of my friends and it's
really it's it's horrible and it's a
horrible thing to see but you go i don't
i would not want to have a kid and that
be their eventuality and the same if
you've got a mother who's a drug addict
right but there's also any other but
that's just how you like that's like
your world view is that if people are
into it go into adoption or foster care
it's an automatically a negative
experience no it's not but this is this
is what can i can i finish how can i
finish so so this is what i'm saying
like like there's kids that come out of
that and they get into really good
situations it's like but it's like
that's a lot of luck i think that's very
rare what evidence do you have that it's
rare well in the uk i can only speak for
the uk but if you're in foster care the
experience isn't like oh it was great
and like it's never like i know i'm
talking about i just i'm sure
i'm sure we could pull up a statistic
for this and i would be happy to find it
now yeah
institutionalized children are more
likely to commit crime that's in
psychology and studies based on that and
people that commit command normally have
not a good home life you can infer that
so i do think in the uk
if you're institutionalized or bored for
adoption and put up for foster care yeah
your quality of life isn't the same as
that of if you're living in you're more
likely to experience abuse sexual
violence in the home you're more likely
to be poor you're more likely to commit
crime right so they shouldn't exist
no no no
it's about it all goes down to resources
right it blows down the resources no
one's saying that oh [ __ ] you you're
poor
no
i really
realize even poor people today are
richer than people have been in all of
human history and they didn't do that my
point is actually the opposite my point
is that poor people should be able to
have children and it's awful that people
are in the position where they cannot
and so because they are lacking the
resources which is why i'm tying it
together
it all ties to resources no one is
saying oh we don't care about poor
people i think there are more poor
people in the world there is only two
percent of people in the world are
actually rich
there's less there are more poor people
but you realize but you realize today
even a poor person is rich by in the in
all of human history doesn't matter if
you look yes it does yes but people say
if you have the liberation if you're
looking at it on a history on a history
standpoint saying that more people are
richer and poor
know that if i if i am if you're gonna
if i'm if i'm considerate
yeah if you're gonna say that you're
gonna have to take into consideration
how each um inflation
inflation interest rates whatever you
want to say is increasing value of life
is value of life value of um living
is becoming ridiculously expensive so
even though
even though the poor people would be
historically
much better now than ever right it's
still not at the point where you can say
okay cool that means they're better off
do you know what i mean i don't actually
know if we are better off though because
actually there are way more people now
in debt than there ever was yeah and so
if you're saying like that obviously the
money that we have today is not the same
as it will as it would weigh back in
like in past times so saying this is
like oh yeah the poor people are are
richer than they've ever been if i am
five pounds in debt or ten pounds in
debt i'm still in debt and it's
obviously not on a five pound it's not a
fiver that you're gonna be in debt
you're gonna be in debt thousands and
thousands so like saying oh i i'm out of
a hundred thousand i am out of ten
thousand you're still out of thousands
like right but but what i'm saying is is
that like in in human history most
people didn't have air conditioning most
people have tvs even even some people in
the us that qualify for financial
aid have tvs they have air conditioning
they have things that like people never
had in all of history so all of history
but like what does it matter what
happened yesterday
like we're talking about the president
i mean it says that you have disposable
income if you can buy a tv i don't even
have a team
like history can affect
no it's i'm saying like they didn't need
abortions like that people didn't do
abortions as much as they do now back
then i don't think that's true
or like greek mythology there's loads of
emphasis in ancient cultures like people
just literally used to kill their
children because they didn't want to
have like a baby girl three hundred
thousand per year abortion might not
have been as prominent
right now
but we know it was a thing i know that i
don't know i don't know which year it
was but like um
i think it was victoria victoria era
no not the point um in some in families
right like back then like there was a
very big thing like if a woman
is like
has a baby out woodlock or some
something like that yeah shame like the
baby gets literally just taken away from
the woman like no i mean just it's just
this bad like that in that in that sense
of like obviously a woman that's just
had gave birth to you know that bringing
life into the world and then her father
or mother just grabbing it away and it's
just just literally
always a thing and it's like really
badly documented because no one wants to
document someone killing their own baby
so we don't know exactly how much i
can't give you like oh three hundred
thousand people will die in this show
because it's not gonna be like a
documentation that i can access
for that yeah the other comparing it to
the past isn't really helping yeah the
other thing as well is that you're
looking at a completely
different cultural time in like the same
way when people reference the bible and
things i find it hilarious because it's
like literally this is like thousands of
years ago um like jesus walks among us
it it for me and i was raised catholic
by the way but like it
lost him it for me
it's uh you're looking at a completely
different cultural time family dynamics
very different
and i would also yeah and societal
values and i would say that a lot of
women then would have had and did have
illegal abortions because to have a
child out of wedlock there was so much
shame associated with it and even going
into 50s 60s 70s in england still so
much shame and we see we see even now we
see in in canada babies of indigenous
women dug up in mass graves we see in
ireland the same thing in catholic homes
where these babies who were born out of
wedlocks were taken and or stolen and
they were abused and they were
mistreated and they died as babies and
they were just buried in the grounds in
these hallowed grounds of this church so
my but my point is is that banning
abortion restricting abortion has never
stopped abortion it just stops safe
legal abortions exactly
and then get rid of the baby so question
do you guys really think that the number
of abortions today yeah in 2022 is the
same as a hundred years ago we can never
prove no no i'm asking like you you
really believe that
do you know what and the population
exponentially increases so it's going to
be exponentially bigger than that okay
okay i'm going to say that it's like oh
it's way more okay you understand
obviously you understand what i'm asking
like what is that where you ask i'm
going to say no but i'm also going to
say again i'm going to reference this
thing of family dynamics are different
way more people people
people on the planet
but no but people as well like people
got married younger so more people had
children but more people had bastard
children yeah people had well there was
shotgun weddings in boston yeah yeah
there were shogun weddings right
americans lead the way don't you looking
at a time
when people actually in general had less
sex like or if people did it was like
especially shameful for women so men
would go to prostitutes and things like
that like when you're looking at kind of
victorian times like there's that whole
thing so i would say you can't really
compare the two because they're very
very different times but
but
but you would agree with me then so like
abortions yeah i would say yes but it's
not it's not like what is what does this
prove like what does this say about
society but i think like like because
then there was consequences and then
people took responsibility for their
actions and they made better choices
and they were miserable and shamed and
put into it
why do you just assume they were
miserable
i'm not assuming they're miserable i'm
just saying like what relevance does
that have have you ever read tessa the
derbavilles oh my god it literally
retested overviews by thomas hardy um
classical literature about uh she names
her baby sorrow she's she's
this very kind of
uh uh blurred lines between was she
raped does she want it or not but
basically she has sorry great but she
has this child and is born out of
wedlock and she names it sorrow and the
baby dies and she can't bury it in
hallowed ground because it's an
illegitimate child she's miserable
everybody's miserable and it's a
commentary really on like actually how
people were treated then and even like
even chatting to my dad now so my dad he
wasn't born out of wedlock but he his
parents got divorced in the 50s or early
60s which was really really rare and he
was bullied and his family was shamed
and it was it was it was not a nice
thing my dad did not have a good time of
it with regards to that
and chatting to him about that he says
but the people who had children out of
wedlock
back then oh so bad and even when i was
being raised my dad said to me you know
don't by the way do this because even
though it's not like it was back don't
do work don't have a child out of
wedlock okay
um and again personally i wouldn't but
that's because i want stability for my
child right um but i
yeah he he said to me you know of the
time even when he was a child women have
women having children out of wedlock was
such an awful thing and you're looking
at a hundred years after
i mean it is an awful thing you put your
kid at every statistical disadvantage
exactly so like that's why you should
get married before
before you carry no before you're here
before you carry it some people just
don't even believe in marriage so then
what happens to that what happened
some people don't believe in marissa
should they not have kids
no
really really but how does that happen
she's very christian like that i
actually wanna how does marriage value
your love to one another to me
personally marriage is just um
reiterating what you already have right
and then writing it down on a piece of
paper it if that's the only thing that's
holding you together really i feel like
it's just a concept to actually make
more money in a way because i don't
think you actually have to get married
to show each other the love and
commitment that you have for each other
if you want if you want to take like
like people that do something similar to
marriage but maybe get the government
out of it like fine yeah that's that's
close enough right because i mean i'm a
conservative we're anti-government
anyway you can get them out of it but
like i think it's important to build a
family it's better for kids to have both
parents in the home 100 so i mean if
they're living as a married couple like
fine but do i think people should plan
to be single parents no 100 no no like
that's terrible some women do actually
just go out and have ivf or do that and
go go yeah and then go and get right um
adopt you i mean do you think single
parents should adopt
like if i'm like i want a kid i don't
have a partner but i think she's like
are you against are you against that
i feel like i feel like it's viable if
i'm like a healthy person i'm wealthy
and i want to adopt you think that's a
bad decision
i guess because this is my thought
that's when i think about that i think
i do think it's it's selfish to be a
single parent and like choose that but
at the same time if the kid has no one
and their option is like foster care or
a single parent like obviously i picked
this thing like someone's better than no
one yeah but
like the girl's doing ivf as like single
i think i think that's selfish i think
you're putting what you want over what's
best for like your kid i think it's
quite empowerful that women would want
to or even a man would want to bring up
a child
by himself no one's saying that they
can't get the
um
feminine aspects of the masculine assets
from different friends and learning up
to growing that environment and
atmosphere i feel like if you take on
that responsibility of having a kid by
yourself you need to make sure that you
provide them with the um
resources that you would do if you were
in a
two-parent two-parent
also i think it's important to point out
that having uh um having both parents in
your life having say
in this argument obviously we're talking
more like heteronormative so a man and a
woman
so having both figures in your life uh
it doesn't really count for a lot if one
of your parents is abusive in which case
i would argue that it's better to be a
single parent than have right that's an
abusive personality i agree with you but
that's an exception but my point is that
i think we
i think we we view single parents we
very much still ostracize single parents
and we very much still have this view of
like no no one i don't think anyone
really
most most okay most people don't go out
of their way with the intention of being
a single parent because most people know
that having stability having two parents
in terms of co-parenting in terms of
actual time you can give to that child
it's beneficial financially it's more
beneficial everybody's very aware of
that so i would say that
i would say that the the
the ostracization of single parents and
that
normally tends to fall on single mothers
because they tend to be the primary care
they're in charge of sex
no they tend to be the primary carers in
most cases they tend to be the person
who ends up with the child if the
parents split up right because i don't
think a lot because the justice system
doesn't favor men but also there's a lot
of men who don't want to be in their
kids lives or there's men who have gone
to prison and
and forfeit that right to be in their
child's life right or their women
there's lots of
okay but does that just because i picked
someone does that mean i deserve to be
with an abuser you don't deserve to be
with like i mean it means we should pick
better okay but some some people are
naive some people are coming because
there's always something like that
always an excuse like like every time
every time i say
women no no let me finish every time
i say women should be accountable for
their actions there's it's always like
everyone's reaction immediately is
excused yeah me being abused is not me
um not being held accountable for my
actions that's me saying i don't deserve
to be abused and sometimes people sneak
their way in people change over time
some people can't become like a for sure
there are some people and we had this
conversation when when i came on before
and i said for sure there are some
people where you
know what kind of person they are before
you continue to keep things
no no i don't mean in terms of staying
with them because people were very
manipulative so sometimes within a
relationship it's like they turn like
this but they tell you no i love you
anyway they manipulate you but i'm
saying from the officer if you know what
kind of person they are then obviously
you kind of you are
asking for trouble in the sense if you
go with someone where you're like yes i
know he is a convicted felon rapist
domestic abuser but my point is that for
most people for the majority of cases
that's not what domestic abuse is
emotional physical that's not how it
goes down
well we were talking i was talking about
jail
like prison like women women
men that are in prison are more likely
to reproduce than men that aren't
would you say that because women because
women are supposed to no because because
they're the danger
the
women are bad at picking
wait hold on do you mean
are you easier to get sex and then
obviously we
like
how like a lot of women are attracted to
the the bad guy yeah 20 percent
so there are isn't it 20 percent that
you should maybe just yeah 20. 20 so 20
of like women 80 of women want 20 yeah
20 of men but i'm saying men that are in
prison
reproduce more like have more kids than
men that aren't yeah so to me that says
something about women's ability to pick
like we're not very men though yeah
defend the male aspect of it when i do
understand where she is coming i do
understand where you're coming from
at the same time you do have to
understand that it's like the evidence
you're giving there's a massive global
and then there's how many people are
actually in jail and then that might be
the 20
in that jail with actually is targeted
by the eighty percent i've said this
i've said this in the previous podcast
this is this is kind of like exactly the
same theory as like if um i've said this
to pearl but i'm murdered by my
boyfriend
whereas like if you've seen the
documentary it's a real documentary
so basically a guy meets the guy meets a
girl it was all nice and whatever like
you know he showed a good side of him
that's how she got that's how he got her
and then later on that's when the
domestic violence came in the moral of
the story at the end of it she got
murdered by she they had a kid and they
now she was like kind of forced to stay
with him did he stay with him then they
kind of split apart and then they got
back together and then the the end of
the story was um she got killed by her
boyfriend in her house with a ironing
board that's a that's a true i remember
this i remember this but it happens a
lot i think so definitely
so what do you want for women do you
want them
to take accountability yeah
because i just think we live in a world
where women don't take accountability
and i can see it like when we're talking
because every time i say like women need
to do something better there's always an
excuse
and so it's like why is that i say women
should be careful who they sleep with
that should be agreed no women shouldn't
agree women should stop picking men in
prison
[Music]
women women should be responsible with
who they sleep with and
and and there it really shouldn't be an
excuse to get pregnant because there's
so many forms of
contraception that's different
and so and then you think capitalized
societies do you know what i mean like
it's so inhumane of us to just think
okay cool like i'm just going to think
of the uk and the us and well-developed
countries when there's like
a ridiculous amount of other countries
that don't have at all the
mindset the the resources nothing the
society that we even have to even
develop i would i would guess that we
have more abortions than those countries
honestly because we have the lack of it
right or it's because like it's because
of our values as a society like it's me
me me me it's like i don't want the um i
i'm too broke to have this kid it would
like it would be too much of an
inconvenience to my life it's not the
right time it's me me me me me where
other societies vam you felt family and
culture
i was going to say look at the amount of
in developing countries look at the
amount of children who are born of rape
who have who become hiv babies and
things like this but exceptionally in
that aspect because it actually happens
in some in some
third world countries it's acceptable
yeah which ones
um for example
even south korea right south um is this
no north korea is like that there's
there's i've i've heard i even think
what a dignity
i mean yeah but do you see what i mean
like there's i don't know i think i
think abortion is the least of their
problems in north korea yeah it's like
that's what there's there's also there's
just it's just me trying to there's
quite
my point yeah there's quite a few
african countries too like within africa
within like 70 years rape i think it's
like 60 degrees great great yeah it's
insane
it's just so like it's it's very it's
very high and what i think the point
that you're trying to make is that we
cannot just look at this obviously in
this case we're discussing because this
is to do with america yeah we're saying
in general there is a larger argument
right for uh for abortion than than and
to do with contraception as well like
contraception is really not readily
available in a lot of developing people
but i'm saying like we keep moving the
goal posts but like
but but it is because i said in the
beginning no because i said in the
beginning we're talking about the us and
the uk
and so then it's like when that argument
starts to go it's like we move the goal
post okay but i don't think i don't
think the argument has gone because i
think what we're saying we're still
saying that you're still reiterating the
same point and we're still reiterating
the same point you're saying you know
there's so much contraception available
and we're saying actually for a lot of
people that contraception isn't
accessible isn't it free in the uk yes
it is free in the uk yes
condoms are damn near for you can get
them no condoms are free condoms are
free no but she's talking about in
america i i i thought
like i i'm saying this as someone i have
really i have really good insurance and
like not just like like one insurance i
have really good insurance i go to like
um
you have health care
and that's like do i
no like youtube
but no i'm saying this as someone that i
am privileged to have um
good health care and
in that like
i've never i've never like this is not
something that is really available i i
in and this i should have the resources
when i am able to afford these things
but if i as someone who is able to
afford these things right have not been
given this obviously i have because my
mom like
raised me like and that's the thing like
my mom has been able to provide these
resources for me but take me out
and
you have to acknowledge that a lot of
people in america do not have the
resources and if i am saying if i'm on
the privileged side and have not been
given access outside of my own mother
like my own home providing more for me
and a lot of people can't provide for
themselves or like you know the health
care because here in the uk nhs like
yeah sure it's free on that side but in
america a lot of times i know i think
birth control is free for certain people
or depending on the insurance you have
like my insurance is free but that is an
exception on the on the site that most
americans are impoverished okay so
do you really you do you think that
condoms are unaffordable for the lower
class
or do you think they choose not to use
them
i think it's both i think it's both and
i'm not saying that to side with either
i think that it is a good thing to be
looked at um to actually analyze and see
something
keep going i'm listening yeah but i
think it is like
i think some people are like choosing
not to and it's always going to be some
people that don't care but then there's
also people 24 for 12 pounds
yeah but that's even england but then
i'm i'm going to the fact of in america
yeah more people are impoverished and
you can't you can't be naive to say that
no
majority of people are are not and but
it all goes down to like what you really
want in life because sure if you saved
like a few more dollars then sure you
could afford that but so i think i think
you can afford it yeah so so wouldn't
you agree it's more of a choice i don't
think contraception's the argument we
should look at i think at the heart of
this is is education because they've
already shown so
for reference but does that all go to
resources the secondary school though we
just we sort of agreed to finish sorry
the secondary school that i went to
had the highest teen pregnancy rate in
the whole of europe that was my
secondary school yeah quite an
impressive figure
where did you go the dork and technology
college in swindon
um and they helped it for many years yes
swindon
where the hell is that
trust
which also ties into the fact that my
school had some of the lowest grades in
nationwide
we see that in people who are more
educated
people who are more privileged have had
a better education better schooling
they have lower rates of especially teen
pregnancy and unwanted pregnancies
that's not a coincidence a lot of the
schools which have the worst education
they suffer a lot on things which are
not classed as essential such as we call
it pshe in england which is like covers
a lot of sex ed and also just general
female female health and male health in
terms of like um periods and things like
that too
but
[Music]
if you have access to that education for
some some people aren't eve i remember
sat in this ph pshe class this girl
didn't know she was 15 years old didn't
know
how many holes you had didn't know that
you she like she she hadn't she she
hadn't yet had her period and she
thought that it came out your bum mm-hmm
like she
so but but we laughed but people
genuinely don't know yeah
if people aren't there
at home then people need to be taught in
schools but if you are as a school
pushing abstinence whilst also trying to
crack down on abortion you're arguing
two different things here because if you
tell people if you educate people
properly on how to have safer sex
the statistics show you are less likely
to have unwanted pregnancies whereas if
you only educate abstinence don't have
any sex and you don't teach the rest you
have higher cases it's not true there's
no evidence that indicates that sex ed
is an effective form of preventing
pregnancies there are more abortions now
than there were before sex ed and no
this is this is what i'm saying i went
to a catholic school we they did preach
abstinence we had no teenagers privatize
school so like you're getting a better
you're getting over a better education i
i went to and i'm saying like say as far
as on the health side i'm saying that i
can ask you one question real quick so
do you really think that most people
sleep like sleep having sex in high
school don't know what condoms are
do you some people and that person like
what percent
if you go like out of every 10 kids
having sex
it goes down to a socio-economic level
because if you're
public school not not private school
because you went to a private school so
that's a totally different totally
different realm but if you are looking
at private schools private
public schools are funded on a
socio-economic level so although they
are all
government schools if this neighborhood
is uh has a revenue of of five right
yeah so you're only going gonna have 5p
to put back into the school yeah whereas
a school that i went to i went to like a
very wealthy
public school
we didn't talk about these things like
we kind of did but i think like most of
the people in the room were
on the advantage of having those but i
will say that there are people that did
not have like these conversations at
home or were not able to they didn't
have these resources and so i think is
is very ignorant to say yeah well like
everyone should no everyone shouldn't
because everyone doesn't have the same
um socioeconomic like so so do you think
people from a lower socioeconomic
background a lot of them don't know what
condoms are no
it's not not not that condoms overall
but like
safe sex
yes like these things are not being
taught and if you assume
i assume you're making an ass out of you
and me so just
no no no
that's that's literally what it is
because
i can't i can't just go into a situation
and assuming that i know everything
that's why in different situations you
have to make sure that everyone is on
the same page so if there's no way or
nowhere along the lines that we like sit
down and say hey where are you at where
are you at and making sure that we're
all like say how we're in this
conversation right now unless that we
know for sure
that we've had the opportunity and given
everyone a space to identify what is
what and say yeah how they feel you can
never say oh well yeah oh you really
think these people aren't educated yes i
really do think these people aren't
educated because no one ever sat down
and had a conversation and said well i
know this at my socioeconomic level and
this school knows this like no there's
no way and it's just blissfully ignorant
to say that you think that everyone has
no everyone doesn't and it goes to the
fact of socioeconomic like
public schools are okay
on that like do you get what i'm saying
public schools have more sex ed than
private school so wouldn't you know
maybe more educational it wouldn't be
more educated no because if you're so
wait wait can i can i ask you a question
you don't think if one school has sex ed
and one school doesn't have sex ed
though the school with sex ed would have
more education on it you can do biology
and that covers what it should cover you
know no but they're actually talking
about they have actual like sex ad in
public schools they don't have them in
private schools they don't actually have
them in private schools but if you're
period not okay but let's not catholic i
mean i don't i don't know about that uh
take the subject out if the subject like
no matter the subject if the subject all
around math science whatever if the
subject is not being funded at all how
can you say oh well yeah you all it's
like that's where you go into from
equality to equity because sure they all
had the same opportunity but they were
not giving the same advantages so
it you just it just sounds like it is
you've also just admitted yourself a
really good point of like you're
speaking on behalf of catholic
that's what i'm saying i i'm on the same
we were both privileged in this
situation i started out in private
school because my mom wanted me to have
the best opportunity and then like
but that is not most people are in
public schools and that's why i'm
emphasizing on the point of
socio-economic impact and then in this
because of these socio-economic impacts
like that are funding the public schools
it goes from
these schools are all equally public
schools so they have the resources i
understand i understand there's a
difference in like there's a difference
in funding for schools but what i'm
saying is i think most poor people know
what condoms are okay
i think it's kind of condescending to
insinuate they don't know
like that's sort of like like okay poor
people argument about like sex ed and
like learning about these things so if
no i've been asking you okay regardless
the argument guys one more time please
you're not answering her question
sorry the last okay i'll i'll say this
and then after this you can cut me off
okay but the last thing that she was
saying is that um
[Music]
you're you're cutting off saying like
teaching safe sex while saying no
abortion so at some point you have to
do more here
to decrease here so if you're not doing
more of sex ed
then you can't like
but what what evidence do you have that
sex ed
decreases abortions
and i've read books on like them
bringing in sex ed into schools that's
the only reason i know this i don't i
don't expect like you to i probably
would think the same thing look at
holland holland has
rated one of the best sex educations in
the world and they have one of the
lowest rates of teen pregnancy they have
some of the lowest rates of stds
have you seen some of their laws like
that
what are some of their laws i don't know
but they're crazy my uncle monk used to
work then
it's like when you have children there
it's like it's it's weird i don't know
exactly what the laws are but like i've
heard it right you're saying lose at
first no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no i meant to say like in a
sense of like
when in holland it's like when you have
a child or something like you should the
laws are very like
i want to say strict
how it is in the us but i know in the uk
even i'm just talking from my school and
obviously some of my friends have been
to different schools um before they
teach sex ed um
they actually give a form to you to give
back to your parents and they actually
say okay mom dad are we allowed to teach
your child sex ed yes no if so what can
we teach them there's like sections abc
whatever the hell it is like i don't
even remember because my mom didn't give
me that privilege of going to see a
freaking sexy
a lot until i was around what 15 yeah do
you know what i mean and i can probably
say the same about my little sister so
my mum never taught me
my mum probably told me where the baby
comes out of because i probably asked
that question but when it comes huh what
story did you get oh it came up
yeah yeah um so
i never got any talk about the stds any
talk about health like health
precautions that you need to take i
didn't even know
how honest to god i didn't know how to
shave my down down there until i was
like what bro you got tired of school no
no i'm saying my mum didn't allow me to
watch sex ed but yet she didn't really
teach me the fundamentals of
sexual harassment do you know what i
mean so it's like i guess were you
wildin
girl
no
no it took me a while it took me a while
i'm just curious like were you a wild
teenager i was not without the sex
that's that's crazy
like i wasn't but my mom was quiet no i
actually wasn't i was like i don't know
conservative i was quite everyone was
yeah you know what i mean that was just
they're like this is intriguing like
what is going on you know what i mean
but my mom's quite conservative in the
way where she i personally think she
finds it uncomfortable to talk about
certain things right no i yeah so when
it comes down to actually having sex ed
a lot of parents wouldn't tick yes
because they are uncomfortable for some
for their child to know that did you
know what a condom was
honestly i
couldn't i tell you i knew what uh i
didn't even know a guy's penis looked
the way it did until i didn't either
until
no until i saw obviously when porn was
introduced corn was introduced to me but
um thank you thank you
um but um
i honestly i do feel like i like the
value in sex ed and
obviously because of my sexuality didn't
lead me to have a um
heteronormative
a baby yeah do you know what i mean so
so it's kind of like
yeah you can say public schools had sex
ed but also you have to look at how
it was back at home and the the
information and the family construct you
have back at home as well well it just
it just seems like that's what i think
it's more the family and the values you
raise with your family yeah okay and
that's why that's why like it goes back
to like
like values yeah like okay regardless of
like contraception and education like
back to the point of like just abortion
in general so imagine if everyone's
educated but everything you need to know
about sex yeah and everyone knows
do you still feel like abortion should
be allowed
like for everyone it's a question for
everyone so if everyone knows
exactly what will happen yeah if you
don't have safe sex and everyone is
educated like the best you can does
everyone still believe that
we should allow abortion i still feel
like this should be a choice
yeah
i still think that um
yeah i still think that abortion should
be allowed yeah even if like regardless
of like even if it's like yeah i don't
care it's not my business it's like if i
choose not to do it then that's that
that's for me but i can't decide for the
next person and i believe i believe in
the bible so that's why i don't believe
in it for me but i'm not to tell the
next person because according to the
bible all sins are equal and then also
if you're looking at it on the stance of
the amendments um america was founded on
separating church and state so if the
the foundation is saying that religion
right
and the laws should be separated why are
you infringing your religious views on
that because to me it's not about
religion it's about biology but unique
can i finish i it's i have a they have a
unique dna sequence from the second
they're conceived
that doesn't mean that they um
are a human being and the it's created
to me how you can your brain starts
formula forming immediately no i
understand but you it's because brain
activity had three weeks exactly
you're also very much shaped by your
upbringing and your religious upbringing
everyone else yeah that's the only thing
that i'm saying
so but so does your v your views are
colored by the way you were everyone's i
was raised catholic but i was raised to
to for
not like the only sex education i had
was being shown a picture of what
gonorrhoea looked like in school right
right but i'm saying i'm saying i'm
saying it like
you know but i'm saying it's not really
relevant like what your upbringing was
it what's relevant is i think it's
always right
why the what's relevant
it's is relevant is is it right or is it
wrong but you're like you're basing that
off of your religious views no like
because no i'm i'm like you're morally
i'm trying to on your religion no right
but she said no i'm saying it's not it's
not based i'm not even that religious of
a person to be honest i'm not like a
bible thumper i don't
like no
no i'm not like i'm not like a super big
bible thumper like i'd consider myself
christian but i'm not like but it's
crazy but can i finish but i'm saying
like like i just i genuinely believe
that's a life and i believe that's
murder so that's not not a religious
belief
that's based on that's based on an and i
have a brother that my my parent gave up
for adoption and i've seen adoption work
in my family you can believe it's life
but you can't i i find it very hard to
um
weigh out
the
values of a human being that's already
alive that's already alive have
cognitive behavior whatever whatever
category um characteristics you want to
put to a human being and then compare it
to a bunch of cells yeah i also don't
think i don't think
there's a difference between a bunch of
cells and a unique dna code i understand
that but at the same time that unique
dna code is
still not formulated into what makes a
human being what the actual definition
of a human being is i'm gonna stop you
right there because that's gonna be my
next question but i think we should read
super chats because we have to
we're going to get dragged out
that's going to be my next question but
oh my god
bro
like it went crazy chat went crazy
um she's gonna read this super chat
don't be dyslexic
don't be disliked
no because i there's so many i can't
read these um i'm gonna i'm gonna read
the last one i'm house of hass
you ladies need to judge stop being
scared accountability is important sex
is not a toy you're pro-choice but
you're against but you're also against
sex in the city culture promoted by
media and society um the next one is
from
the next one is from best djf my mom
taught a b sex um okay what is a b sex
just they're gonna they're gonna read
them all in a row okay so we have han
and g planned parenthood opposed a bill
to make birth control the counter
planned parenthood makes birth control
conception less available for profit
we have sloan fidel
with a hundred dollars
i am in my late 50s with the 28 year old
girlfriend i am president of two
companies so i understand what is going
on with young people i'm impressed with
your show i never thought i would see a
young woman like you fighting for unborn
rights love your show
and
with you that's an interesting
perspective we got there
uh
clockwise
dan paul looking fine at af today nice
dress love i told you the floral i told
you the floral yeah
um we have
taylor johnson all those women don't
want
i'm not consequences
if you don't grow up
if you don't grow up catholic you don't
know what that sex leads to babies
what the
okay i mean yeah wtf uh bigotry of low
expectations
uk economist why are women choosing men
who don't want to use contraception
surely those men aren't a good choice
peter pitta
at pearl strongly recommend this red
pill the anti-marry expose rescuing the
cult from toxic femininity kindle
edition 779
on amazon i hope you'll read more
clarity needed uh jjm one two one
uh what if and appealing to fringe cases
the in nev the inevitable answer to call
for accountability
marianne
moving on lost souls uh the
radicalization of these issues is a
mistake for both sides of the issue
abortion as a process or a procedure
isn't bad if even
if even has some value in current
religious context how folks use it isn't
good
we have more super chats coming in
um
yeah taylor johnson uh black woman love
to opt out of con conversations by using
the you're not black argument that is
code for you don't know exactly so
you'll just shame i'll just shame you
wait ish can you read that i'm sorry
okay black women love to opt out of the
conversations by using the you're not
black argument
basically we're not opting out we're
telling people that they can't have that
experience
so we're opting them if you're ignorant
of something i mean i'm i like to learn
about things so if i don't know about
something i'd rather someone that is
experiencing that field to tell me so
like i mean wouldn't you want to hear
that your experience is not going to be
the same like i mean and you can see
statistically like there are countless
like things that prove
that we are not going to have the same
experience we can have every
characteristic the same aside from our
our skin color and our hair and could
have completely different lives you can
even be in like worse um predicaments
than me and then be better off just
because of your race
[Music]
i didn't make that up well i just think
it's like
i don't
like group people like that because i
think every like black person is going
to have a different experience
experience like i've met black black
people that are from nigeria and black
people are from america and they're
gonna have completely but they're gonna
have a collective black experience i
think they're just talking black and
black and white literally like just a
collective i don't think they're talking
about like um different origins yeah but
just literally yeah spain like like
honestly
people who do say that type of stuff it
um
it's not on opt out almost it's just
still trying to bring awareness to the
matter of fact that actually
that black people don't get the same
black women in this
instance don't just get don't get the
same um privileges that one women do not
even the statistics aren't even yes but
the statistics are there to show you
that it actually does
is in this um actually does favor the
lighter complexions than the darker just
because
of just how it my point is it's just
like it's different for every person so
like willow smith is going to have a
completely different experience
but that that's the classism right right
but that's what i'm saying like i just
don't like group people by like i think
that you say that because you haven't
had that experience anyway you don't see
it how important i'm not saying like i'm
i'm saying like i just feel like people
are different like they're individuals
no and no one's saying that it's a
hundred percent like yeah and this is
not an attack on you but it is very
ignorant to say oh i don't see color
because i'm not
i'm saying in the instance of like oh
well i don't think this is the same
experience or i personally don't see
color whether you see the color or not
or you think that
this may or may not happen to certain
people it's reality for most like
acknowledge it like yeah like you have
to acknowledge it if uh
if multiple people are saying this is my
experience and it's like oh well this is
how you're saying this is the exception
well
the exception is that some don't have
that experience but most do
and you just have to acknowledge it that
most do this this is that most have
like someone from nigeria and someone
from america are going to have the same
experience if we come those people will
have this those people will have the
same experience in regards to how they
are treated and discriminated against
yeah like competitively perspective so
you can say yeah of course the person in
nigeria will have a different experience
but then that's just branching off from
the bigger do you know i mean even in
nigeria you see a massive thing with
skin bleach color
like colorism yeah like you probably
would university
if you were lighter yeah but also i
think this person here is just
completely disregarding i think it's a
very valid point that you guys are
making that actually we will we will
never understand that i will never
understand as a white woman the
experiences that you've had i don't see
that day to day i hear from you guys i
hear second hand i may see it but i
don't experience it myself and so for me
it's an opportunity to learn when when
someone who is non-white says this is my
experience i've had it's a fact they're
they're stating and it is very
objectively it's it's simply a fact that
black and white people are treated
unequally that is true
universally
for me that's an opportunity then to
shut up and listen
and to learn but also to accept the fact
that it's a fact and it's not as this
person is saying playing the race card
or you're just trying to give an excuse
no you're objectively stating
that this is going to be different do
you think it's like
racist to assume all black people have
the same experience
we're not saying that like because
you're kind of saying like everyone has
the same experience based on the colors
i think you're really over generalizing
that but we're saying like collectively
the majority of black people
will have a collective experience so
let's say a black person from anywhere
in the world goes to america and gives
birth to a child yeah their collective
experience will be different to a white
person that gives birth twitter well
sure yeah that's what we're trying to
say and there will also be variations on
that obviously taking into account your
class because if you yeah if you're
willow smith you're like a billionaire i
have to end this i think we need to read
like a million of course sorry sorry i
apologize
um so best djf uh why do you have to
kill the fetus why can't we keep them
alive harvest their organs later
my man yes keep the fetus alive if
you have a black strong take it off
or live or one day they have a fetus
ready to be harvested
never let me go which is an incredible
book but i've been watching diaries when
they dissect it
yeah
okay uh so dragon's pride human brain
doesn't fully develop till late teens
almost 20s from what i've heard read
that's true okay
sentience with fifty dollars
[Music]
a bunch of cells don't constitute a
human life
have you listened to yourself even in
the slightest all cells are alive plants
animals humans etc you must have life in
that otherwise it would be considered
inanimate uh definition of words matter
patter
foreign
not about sorry not about pushing you
it's about caring for your life and
other human organisms lives bodies and
souls scientifically humans sorry
scientifically human organisms begin to
extend oh sorry
scientifically human organisms begin
extinct at contraception uh you assume
that human life is not
to be honest
okay
sp jack if we discover a few things that
are living cells on mars we have
discovered
extraterrential life just a few clumps
of the cells
jjm121
very enlightening listening to these
very selfish women argue for not being
held accountable
more the more i watch this type of
sorry the more i watch this type of
content the more convinced i am that
life is not just about
self
[Laughter]
uh to anyone who asks if the woman
cannot give their child the xyz
in relation to human life why didn't you
think of that before allowing a man
between your legs and impregna and
impregnating you why do feminists always
think about choice after they make the
bad decision
keep going okay cool sam
pearl's legs
sorry paul's got a cute feet
with that man bro why are you laughing
so loud
is that the demographic we got here
or what about tree is a variant of
logical
fallacies that attempt to discrete or
sorry i'm going to read that again uh
what about ism or what about tree is a
variant of logical fallacy that attempts
to discredit
and oppose oppositions by changing or by
charging hypocrisy with direct refuting
or disproving the argument i don't know
what he meant by that [ __ ] can someone
say that that was a lot of words
keep it going
all right amir ali i think men should be
pro-wallet thank god i live
in the west
um
best djf um
guys there's literally no need to kill a
fetus i can guarantee the mother or
relatives will need organs later
in a 20 to 30 in 20 to 30 years you'll
have a full grown organ i'm not sure
it's a harvest don't be wasteful
sinister
uh not the children's fault it was
conceived if woke up handcuffed to
someone i can't already cut their arm or
head off uh most abortions are not
stopped
a mother's day sorry most abortions are
not to stop a mother's death they are
just said
as a tactic
uh superpower sensei for all the human
history casuals
uh you know what it is uh has been
rigged um
the game's been rigged for women and it
has not
been great for men it's tragic not evil
okay uh best djf if we keep the fetus
for the rich
this guy
if we keep the fetuses for the rich in
incubators we could charge them millions
to provide the perfect orchid we can use
the money to provide more proportions
sentience 50 dollars again
what a guy um so much on sorry
so much on snipes
so much on stance
wow
i'm trying i'm trying i've been reading
a lot it's tough in these streets man uh
so much on
unsubstantiated feelings in this podcast
the u.s upon contraception uh the woman
has a 100 legal right to do with what
the children child has to seem
i'm tired help me um you got this come
on all right let's keep going so much
times
trying to breathe
it's okay it's okay help me
all right so so much unsubs
unsubstantiated feelings in this podcast
in the us upon conception the woman has
a 100 legal right to do with the child
as she sees fit without consequences men
are bound financially women are 100 in
control of who is born in the u.s fact
the spoken one
women on tick tock saying no abortion
rights no more hookup culture
interestingly how men don't have a say
until abortion rights are under
threat
we're still going
paypal
regardless of how it happened it is
besides the fact the conv that sorry
besides of how it happened it's beside
the fact conceived is a human life the
organ still exists i wonder how many of
you think it's okay to dismiss
possibilities you are killing an unsold
that's dark zenithians with 50 dollars
yes let's go back to sex women control
access to sex stop letting men you
aren't married to between your legs you
wouldn't have any unwanted pregnancies
outside of a crime you can't abolish
your responsibilities this
is while you're only blaming yourself
for one side
sentience again with fifty dollars let's
go
uh the feminine sorry to the feminist on
the sofa
you know who you are
it takes two to tango
but you blatantly ignore the fact that
per data at statistics eighty percent of
women find only the top twenty percent
of men attractive meaning that they are
sharing those top men most men do not
have access to sex
you have a response
spoken about this before okay fair
enough
reception it is a role of a woman and
the man to
be devoted to each other especially if
two become the future parents why is it
being a parent such a bad thing why is
being selfish such a bad thing uh being
a parent is the biggest opportunity and
honor that's come from tim naruto
we've got so much children
okay um
is that the next one han nanji hanji
rape incest is 1.1 percent of abortions
bad faith argument just admit that you
believe the child's life is better is
worse than the woman's quality of life
a hundred ca or 10 cad bad experience is
poor it is not worse than being murdered
and why do you think you can stay for
the child that should die you can't wait
on these terms you all are avoiding the
topic of murder
um these women are um
salone fideli these women are lying to
you and to themselves stand strong
sister you have an army of real men
behind you um marlon sg owned 200 thank
you so much
okay
super chat i like the girl in the white
pants you can see the cogs in her mind
working i still disagree with her but i
enjoy her thought out responses okay
amira ali for 84.99 so these girls um
so these girls prove pearl's point you
should be selective with who you go to
bed with clockwise pearl is feudal
arguing with a person who sees a fetus
as a clump of self side notes how do you
rectify being pro-life and pro-death
penalty i'm gonna answer that real quick
i rectify that because i just think that
anyone that touches a child should die
sorry um
um okay um
20 20 what from temper 83 what is
cheaper for poor people and abortion a
child or contraception
um another 20 from temper past 83 a
healthy discussion means nothing how
many forms of birth control did they
have back then compared to 2022 bear
market dating i've said it once and i'll
say it again
marriage is not about love is about
structuring to give your best offs
you're offstring the best chance of
success that is why it is why it calls
for selflessness
selflessness
um oh my god i can't talk
i was poor had poor health had poor f
had few friends few prospects we ate
roadkill and bred cereal at times a true
adult sacrifices what um their fun for
the child not the other way around lj
soar soren son let's say you had a set
of conjoined
conjoined twins what what are the proper
ethics whether or not one twin could
kill the other if it would improve their
life sb jack you blocked me for saying
safe legal and rare really i didn't do
it i don't know who did that um sorry
mobs okay best dj
af um
wait go back click the other link click
that click that click that and click
that
yeah yeah there you go okay um you're
good
where were we um
okay the next one best dj af italy
france spain all have 14 week week
limits the us has one of the most
alenian abortion rules sweden
sweden california and the uk have kind
of the most
most related abortion rules the majority
of the world is very conservative um
pitopedic conversation has been
everything but the topic of killing a
human creature han nag um an american
most americans are impoverished census
data says 11.4 percent live at or below
the federal poverty line um kenneth
james uh one dollar thank you not even a
message appreciate you um um peter peta
if i woke up today learn where babies
came from and the first time i found out
i got pregnant and was passed out it
isn't okay for me to kill the huge human
organism because i find them too close
to me death dj af these people don't
even know about condoms and er
the people that don't even know about
condoms basically animals know racism dj
f my mom taught me a b sex house of has
you ladies need to stop being scared
accountability is important sex is not a
toy you're pro-choice but you're also
against sex in in the city culture
promoted by the media and society is
that all of them no no
sin more money no problem to have i love
you guys we love you guys
come on guys okay okay
okay there's there's where to end um
okay so it's these so he's fine i'm
um house of has you ladies need to stop
need to ju oh wait i did this one right
okay so kenneth james none of my
girlfriends in high school made me use
the condoms pull out was the move and we
just didn't care sex ed isn't teaching
any anything the internet has it um 4.99
from bez 787 it's scary to think my baby
girl's life could have been ended with a
single decision i am hugging her and not
letting her go she just hit 10 months
just human generally speaking developing
countries have a culture that reprimands
women for irresponsible sex we can't
compare the culture or sexual art
cultural sexual liberation to theirs
black gen z minds that 79 of planned
parenthood facilities are in the black
and brown community oranges or origins
of planned parenthood margaret sanger
was a eugenicist who wanted to control
black birth
marcos garcia if if a woman chose to
have an abortion that in her body then
it is her choice a man
does not want to the man should be able
to have a financial abortion
just human pearl have someone
hire someone to read the super chats
he's getting he's gonna get better
you better start reading more i promise
he's learning okay simone
um if if women always have to give it up
to promote the bad boys is it wrong for
men to emulate their behavior in order
to compete in the secular
sexual market boy type a lot of women
are about my body by choice but when it
comes to abortion but where was all this
right to bodily autonomy during during
forced vaccinations we're not done
there's one more uh three more three
more okay um
sorry guys we're refreshing the
the chat thank you guys i love you um
okay
uh ram at the time va was trying to do
an abortion up to the birth canal and
they never even questioned the extra
punishment for killing someone pregnant
ten dollars um from jeremy fair i came
from a poor background and we have never
met anyone who didn't know what a condom
was this seems to be rooted in this
doesn't seem to be rude in reality at
all is it classism
this needs to be there needs to be some
kind of consequence so abortions don't
happen in the first place hookup
culture is where it
starts thank you from slice of pie
is it trisha paytas who like went on the
ellen degeneres show because she can
speed read really quickly you need help
so question guys um this is one of the
super chats um
so
and we were talking about race a little
bit before um and does it bother you
basically
that 79 of abortion clinics are in
america are in the black and the brown
communities and black women are three
times more likely to get an abortion
than white women and planned parenthood
was founded by a woman who wanted to
eradicate like the black race so she
decided to put these planned parenthoods
in like black communities
in order and market to black women in
order to like
to basically market abortions to them
and and then um that basically the black
population would be double today if it
wasn't for abortion in the u.s
i'm sorry it's just when they provide um
abortion yeah so the woman that started
it she she believed in like like
eradicated the black race yeah yeah
basically and so she said we're gonna
market like planned parenthood in in
black neighborhoods
and basically
now black women are three times more
likely to get an abortion and the black
population would be double today if in
the u.s if it wasn't for abortion so it
kind of worked
yeah i'm uncomfortable with the idea
eugenicist
has
had i'm speaking the wrong language now
have been successful and
okay sorry
i've got a really bad voice today so i
might whisper i don't know if
whispering's better no whispering is way
worse
speak into my okay
so
i'm uncomfortable that someone that had
that kind of plan
had succeeded in that kind of plan in a
sense but i do think that abortion
is still valid and people still need to
need that option and it isn't what it is
it isn't the same as it was in the past
so now it's not just for black women
it's not targeted just a black woman
it's available to all races and all
people but i do feel like there is still
the history in that culture maybe
of abortion or going to planned
parenthood or in impoverished areas or
typically systematically oppressed areas
where abortion is like the only option
that's marketed to those people if you
know what i mean i'm uncomfortable with
that but i'm not uncomfortable that
there's a choice
because i want people to be able to
choose
what they do with their bodies at the
end of the day i'm uncomfortable though
eugenicist has had successfully done
that in a sense it makes me
uncomfortable my my question is if black
women are having more abortions than
white women in these areas
is that because
they're falling pregnant more
that is my question is it as opposed to
they're more likely to get an abortion
if they do fall pregnant as opposed to
the amount of people who do because then
i think we've got another argument again
about if if the majority of people who
are impoverished in america within these
communities are black
then
that is another reason why more black
women would be falling pregnant and as
well if a lot of black men in those
communities commit crime because poverty
different reasons you know um
systemically oppressed uh-huh
then is that why these women are also
then not statistically more likely to be
sleeping with offenders and things like
that like for me those also that's a
really good connection that you've made
there i didn't get the last bit yeah i
didn't understand so are you saying
so wait so you you think that um
if there's more offenders in your
community statistically you're more
likely to have sex with an offender okay
because of the higher probability you'll
have sex with an offender if there's a
lot more in your community no i so i
meant like you were asking about the
abortion rates uh yes sorry so um is it
the that if you took the same
uh so if you did it as a ratio basically
of like um
[Music]
uh black women
are more likely to have an abortion if
they fall pregnant compared or is it a
case of more black women have abortions
because more black women are falling
pregnant
i think i'm not 100 sure so this could
be wrong but from what i understand and
guys let me know in the chat sometimes
the chat be like factual yeah
um but i think i think it's black women
are more likely to have an abortion i
don't think the falling pregnant rates
are different okay that would i would i
would be interested to know yeah
yeah i think that would make a
difference
like that that would just completely
change like if it would depend it would
really depend on which
statistics is more valuable it'd make me
more comfortable about the idea that
someone that had created that in mind i
think
yeah it's wrong to do that it's to any
race you know i mean eugenics is wrong
period but like so do you think like now
in 2022 like because i'd imagine if nike
was founded
as like they wanted to eliminate the
black race
like people would be in an uproar but
for some reason like planned parenthood
gets a pass when they're they're doing
that
yeah the black population would be
doubled like that's crazy i know what
you mean by that i think i think with it
being a choice so no one is like oh
pearl you go to planned parenthood right
now like you get it like it's you have a
choice in going there um but i think it
is something to
to explore um outside of this and also
see how true these statistics are
because oftentimes they are like skewed
and i'm not saying that they have to be
100 wrong but oftentimes especially when
representing black people they are not
accurate um
and so i i just think it's something to
be explored but if people are like going
there willingly i don't necessarily feel
bad because
likely they're in the situation where
they're not going to be able to take
care of these kids so now you're saying
oh the population could be double but
are you also then saying that it could
be double of
people that are not gonna be loved that
are not gonna be like uh and still like
a value of life like not saying that
their life isn't valuable but they're
not gonna be taught any principles that
are gonna like make or break their life
so now you're saying oh it could be
doubled but in this sense they're not
going to be nurtured so they're going to
be more criminals and now you're going
to say oh yeah like all the black people
are criminals well you just said you
wanted half of them to be here like
double do you get what i'm saying yeah
also on the topic of
redemption and our short-term memory
um
you can also make this argument for the
same of companies like hugo boss who
made this like nazi stuff for nazis and
lots of other german companies uh chanel
coco chanel was a
yeah it was a nazi sympathizer like the
days that were in the past yeah like
completely different people running it
that kind of thing but do you think it's
like
like okay it's one thing right if like
people
choose to get an abortion i understand
it's still a choice but but they're
marketing this to young girls like
they're they're they're specific they
specifically pick
lower income communities and market it
to those communities like isn't isn't
that
yeah they talk about that how do they do
they have tv ads and stuff that they
only show in these communities
well
i i want to say it's either 69 or 70 of
all the abortion clinics are located in
those communities and then and then and
then on top of that like like margaret
um like the lady who started it had like
a a marketing plan written out talking
about how she wanted to market it but
like how did she do it i've never
actually seen now that you've i've never
actually seen a an abortion mob
i've never marketing schemes i've never
seen it ever or right anything i do i've
never hey
necessarily advert in that sense but i
think as far as placement and just you
saying that like
it really
thinking because obviously i'm the only
one aside from pearl that's from america
and thinking about the like
uh like planned parenthood's um
that i know of
i don't i'm pretty sure it's not the
only one but the only one that i can
think of is like in a lower income area
um with
an immense amount of marginalized people
so
it's somehow i don't think it's just
there but i think it is something to
explore like i think overall it is a but
is that the only place you can get an
abortion yeah
they don't only certainly like that's my
question to you no no guys one at a time
please i'm saying like it's kind of it's
kind of like when you think about it
it's kind of messed up because it's like
then only the rich like it's almost
and i don't think people directly mean
this but in a way it's saying that only
like rich lives are more valuable
because that's where the planned
parenthood is but can you only get an
abortion at planned parenthood or can
you get it at like a doctor like yeah
this is my question because then that's
a case of it's not just about pampers
planned parenthood because you have
money to afford to go private you can go
to your doctor that's in your own area
yeah
but while we're mentioning this thank
you for bringing that up um a lot of um
white people will especially like say in
politics will
say
say i'm a senator and you're my daughter
well i don't i'm saying oh no abortions
no abortions i'm sure so not letting you
be known for your abortion right so i'm
going to take you privately and no no
one's knowing about this abortion and
we're not utilizing these government
services i'm going to my privatized
health care but that's that's more than
that so you can have five
but the average white person isn't
making that kind of money like like the
average white person isn't in that
income bracket where they're in a
politician situation where their height
like that's not a a wealth advantage
like generational wealth but it's a
thing you have to acknowledge that
sure sure generational wealth is a thing
yeah so you're gonna have more resources
and more money like a lot of black
people are starting their generation one
two generations ago as far as like their
money whereas white people can go back
to the beginning of slavery or like
settling in america
so yeah you can look at it on a
different app necessarily because the
majority of people in the us came from
like after slavery but still even the
ones like that came like towards the end
they were able to benefit off of the end
of slavery and these different jobs that
were repurposed after slavery and able
to like start working like black people
were not able to like
sustain a living or earn
in this sense like white people at the
end of day are like
america is built to benefit white people
right so at the end of day
you won't see it because it's not meant
to be like hey
you guys are being like treated better
it's it's very what did you say this is
like contributing to the problem though
if they're marketing abortions to
low-income neighborhoods and they're
basically eradicating
available there but they're not like
marketing you're you're right you're
right it's not only available there but
you don't think it's a little bit messed
up
like that that a huge like i just i
don't know how i think it's sadness
especially like what's messed up about
having
okay accessible healthcare in a poorer
area
no that's not what's messed up but that
is not what planned parenthood is what
are you saying
exactly because what i'm getting from it
is that it's messed up the fact that
sorry
that um
it's messed up the fact that um the
whole thing was built to eradicate that
face that's what i'm well it's a mess
that's meant
to do that and they're doing it that's
what's messed up that's my stuff you
could say okay we have new people in
charge but they're still doing the same
thing
let's talk about from the perspective
okay black people are living in poor
areas and that's where planned
parenthood is for people that don't have
access to expensive healthcare or
privatized healthcare but you can still
get an abortion somewhere else
and it can the location of that abortion
could be in hospital in an affluent area
is that being marketed to rich people
like that logic i don't think it i don't
think it holds well because planned
parenthood is the number one provider of
abortions in the u.s they don't know the
public private abortions are they but
it's number one because obviously it's
the cheapest option
it's it's the most available option
i don't think that because of the
availability in the location it makes it
more
marketing
i can understand both sides and like at
the end of the day i feel like just
overall abortion is someone's choice
like no i don't
most cases people are not being forced
like i feel like
maybe a few years back but most times
now people are getting an abortion by
their own merit so i like i i do get the
argument but
you're choosing to do that so
it's your choice at the end of the day
um
okay fair enough so then the last last
question of the night okay
when when do you guys think life begins
like at what point in a pregnancy are
you do you guys support abortion up to
um
like up to up to birth is that like like
i don't like up to bath it's not like a
comfortable thing
because the thing is um
from like i thought um
from when you get pregnant i think
there's like a certain like timeline i
think that you get between between like
you can have an abortion and it's too
late i think i don't know how long that
is for 24th week yeah there we go so so
i feel like the life would probably
begin i'd say after that because that's
like but that's going off what the like
the dog the doctors are saying that's
what i think you can have an abortion
after that but only if it's got very
serious medical implications and so this
is for me i
believe
that you should have access to an
abortion right the way up until you give
birth if you have
a very serious medical condition i.e the
baby is already dead
and it needs to be aborted because it's
going to be stillborn
or it could kill you or it could
seriously harm you i think that's fine
um
for me i would say up until about the 24
week point this is again not speaking on
i don't know everyone's experiences but
for me
oh my goodness sorry that's crazy i mean
obviously if i if i found out i was
pregnant i would like i would aim to
have the abortion as soon as possible
but how fast can you have the abortion
because you don't find that you're
pregnant until like how many weeks later
yeah yeah no you missed one period
that's one month's time like the second
month
one at a time i think at that point just
maybe just give it up for adoption
because it's like
okay if it's past it's past the clump of
sales so it's like you at that point
everyone should be able to acknowledge
that
the last mile of the race it's like
everyone should be able to acknowledge
that that is actually a baby not like
just to come themselves because you know
after after a couple months
yeah yeah of course i think it's up
until 24 weeks that baby is still not or
the fetus it's not even showing house
24 weeks though no i'm not about it
showing you're not i'm saying like
in in your stomach like rather
like that's illegal like i don't think
you can have a
abortion isn't
in the uk you can't have it unless you
have a really good grounding and a
reason after 24 weeks yeah yeah my point
is so it wouldn't be like that it
wouldn't be an actual
baby that
yeah my point is that for me i i i
personally would advocate until the
24-week point from the point of view
that it's not actually viable outside of
the womb before that point yeah for me
personally i would of course aim to have
it as soon as possible and i
have like pretty regular periods and i'm
pretty honored with regards to testing
pregnancy and also sexual health testing
i encourage everybody to get tested
um to get tested for stds regardless of
if you're actually having protected sex
even if you're with the same partner
yeah just get it yeah but um and so for
me i would hope that i would
be nowhere near the 24 week point yeah i
just i feel like it would be a hard
decision
six months have no periods like
i know someone who who only knew she was
pregnant when she was in labor you know
some people don't actually show them
even have
a yeah
what did she think
did she think she was getting in not
everyone knows some people some people
get pregnant when they're healed some
i kind of want to wrap up the show so
i'm just curious so six months what
would you say
i i cannot even say a proper time but i
feel like you know
girl i don't know how the baby looks but
here we go
bring it up
pick one i think say
yes
that's six months because see that's
like still on the fence but that that's
on the fence no the three
yeah i mean three months for me i would
say like 12 within the 12 week point
like so i guess somewhere between the
three and six months you need to cut it
off because it's gonna be even more
traumatic for everyone else involved
like the people that have to perform
that abortion you've got to think about
those people that's crazy to think about
yeah because as a person like a doctor
or whoever has to do that that is not
going to be comfortable to be pulling
out something that
it looks like that's looking like a lie
they can't just pull it out they have to
like juicy cut it and then they vacuum
let me know
i know it's the truth but i don't yeah i
just think it's true i just think that
um you're between three and six months
you think-ish yeah for like legality but
for me
for you never or for you personally
never like you wouldn't get one but you
would say like legally three to six
months yeah what would you say i'd say
the doctor thing where from from when i
can't have a devotion after that after
what up
24 weeks yeah
okay
wait so you would be okay with an
abortion at eight months i said i feel
like no no no no
i said i when the baby is able to live
by itself out of the womb yeah that's a
good one i believe that's when they
should legalize um illegalize it okay i
want everyone to see the picture and
sure
possible
i feel like it like makes a difference
like looking at it like that but i do
believe that like
um like
you know if the baby is able to fend for
herself uh ting what is that theory like
you know survival of the fittest
basically like if you can't fend for
yourself
what what's the baby gonna do choppers
no
that's not the point
her point is saying that like she
believes that you you should be able to
get rid of the baby until the baby would
be able to survive so like some babies
like so tiny if they're born they can't
survive without you know like breathing
they can't lie by themselves
yeah that goes back to money
because like when the baby would survive
depends on the hospital and it kind of
goes back to it kind of goes back
thousands what that's hundreds no that's
what i'm saying so like if you would do
abortion at the time it would survive
outside the womb that's again good okay
we're not talking about with with
different medical situations and also
financially i'm talking about like
physically viable whether like in even
so i was a premature baby yeah so i had
jaundice i was into law oh so i had a i
look in my baby photos i look like i
have a banging tan no but i'm saying
what i'm saying if you use that logic it
still goes back to the money thing
because again if in a rich neighborhood
they might be able to save a kid at five
months
i don't i don't know what the youngest
is but
the privatized health care is a is very
expensive that money does not stretch as
far as you think it does so
sure you might have like more money than
the next person that it it's very
expensive that's that's my point like
that's the whole point as i'm saying if
you're gonna do it based on when
what like when the baby can survive
outside of the womb that changes based
on how much money you have because in a
poorer hospital it's going to be later
where because they have more access to
medical care and medical profession
i don't even think it is um so you're
saying that if a baby was born at five
months old
that hospital would be able to keep that
baby i'm alive what i'm saying is that
with more resources
and in richer in like richer hospitals
they're going to be able to keep babies
alive sooner
in poorer hospitals they will because
they have they have
because because we let me outfit because
because in the richer areas they're
going to have more access to resources
to keep that baby alive
i'm just i'm just trying to like like
like not like like the best doctors so
so
regardless of any other like resources
doctor resources whatever is that baby
by itself allowed to live outside the
not allowed able to live outside the
room without any intervention by any
type of doctor i've got the answer
so doctors now consider 22 weeks the
earliest gestational age when a baby is
viable
or able to survive outside the womb but
this is still extremely premature and a
baby born at this age will need a great
deal of medical tension and also the
mortality rates for a baby born at 22
weeks would be very very high you would
be very likely for that baby to die
regardless of the
trauma that you're putting on that baby
like like i'm not saying either way but
i'm just saying like think about it
your limbs ripped off but like i
so let me kill a one-year-old baby
because it won't remember one i didn't
say one i said three months old no i
know but because that's a huge
difference in my book like i said those
months add up i still feel comfortable
with what i said ideally within three
months then you have that extra period
up until the point that the baby is
considered viable until you can still
have a comfortable abortion up until
that point for whatever reason
and then i would say after that point
it's only then if it's medically because
like
yeah i mean at that point
for me i'm like look it could i think i
think that this part we probably could
discuss in the next show just because
it's getting so late
um but why don't why don't why don't we
read the super chats
[Music]
no one said i have nice feet yet do i
need to take my seconds
everyone sucks over
please shove them in the camera
oh johnny yeah yeah well i say we're
going to do super chats
send the money so
what was the last chat you read no idea
okay no no you're all good uh slice of
pie
there needs to be some kind
sorry there needs to be some kind of
consequences so abortion doesn't happen
in the first place hookup culture is
where it starts
uh just humane i'm trolling you to read
this powerful
houses of haz
ask them if they support sex in the city
culture
what is that just keep going
michael northsinger
excusing the lack of integrity or
accountability due to social economic
status sounds a lot like the soft
bigotry of low expectations
uh house of has asked them if one could
support abortion and also support sex in
the city culture it seems like it's
failing you g woman
by promoting sex as a toy
manager biologic uh
what does falling pregnant mean uh
meaning she has nothing to do with it uh
the spoken one in the us 50 of black men
are single childless
and are in the middle class rap kevin
samuels
whoa profit cry
that's a real one uh young l thomas
pearl how do you put up with these crap
sorry
how do you put up with this crap spew
excuse the
machines i'm staring right down the
barrel of the lens for that one
sir excuse me
uh house of has cosmos magazine's
marketed it sex and the city culture
markets it it's a business
get it
uh they make it easy
there's community so now you don't have
to properly you don't have the proper
family you don't change your life for
the better because of the family
house of has when it is wrong how many
is it too many aborting uh
dragon station
1001
does woman in the red and white striped
t-shirt realize this very first long
life slave
in
the colonies that became the u.s was a
black man john cassot owned by a black
plant or plantation owner
anthony johnson in virginia
yeah so it doesn't matter what they look
like a slave is a slave like they are
still black the last uh super chat is
from house of hass when is it too many
when do you judge and shut down the womb
grave
when do you judge
and that concludes the super chats
i saw three more
uncommon secret i don't refresh it and
see if i missed any but uncommon secrets
get pearl a tv fro fund
feel free to add to this people i don't
have a tv but i very well could so thank
you
um
another another super chat from ram get
pearl a tv fund add to this folks ram
again don't add me to the uncommon
secrets was there any before those three
those are three okay okay
okay guys um
i know it's late i know it's been a long
show i'm sorry sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry okay guys um so
first of all i wanted to say thank you
guys all for coming um i think this is
like the best show i've ever had to be
honest so i think we should give
ourselves a round of applause
[Applause]
i really enjoyed being able to talk to
you i know we disagree but i think it's
really important we have conversations
with people we disagree with yeah no
definitely you do like i feel like
hearing each other's points as well help
us see how other people would think
because sometimes yeah i could be
oblivious to how actually certain
mindsets things like flaws within our
own reasoning yeah which is important
and so i think it's really great that
like we can have completely different
opinions and we don't hate each other
oh i have a point to add by the way
this is a point that i made right at the
beginning of the podcast and i forgot
that i'd taken a screenshot of this the
statistic that i quoted about um divorce
rates when you're divorced at a young
age versus an older age that's available
on the office of national statistics
okay heads up for anyone who is
pedantic about sources oh okay but yeah
sorry continue no i i um when you said
the 18 i was like oh i know what stat
you're talking about um okay
so
oh there's one more super chat i'm gonna
i'm gonna read it at the end in a second
but um so yeah i really appreciate all
you guys coming like honestly i think
this was clearly but super chat wise
this was my best show ever
send some money if you want us to come
back
watch them just stop sending money
okay so why don't we go around any final
thoughts you guys want to say um tell
people where to find you you start and
then go around this way oof um i won't
say where to find me because just catch
me on just pearly things but um
but i'm jamari
um
i hope
people can take their feelings out of
things because i don't feel any
different like i mean i don't i'm not
hurt by anything that anyone against my
opinion has said and i think just as
people we should be willing and like
wanting to learn and see outside of our
own perspective
um i think that this show was actually
well pretty well pretty good went pretty
well
i mean i had a lot of valid points to
say
um and you can find me down in the
description so
yeah that's me
i
think that
everybody is entitled to their own
beliefs
and i think that everybody is entitled
to bodily autonomy
uh you can find me on instagram at emily
jane shepherd shepherd spell
s-h-e-p-a-r-d
um
thank you very much for having me and i
completely agree that i
don't like you any less for our
differing of opinions
and um yeah i think it's important that
we have these spaces because i think
otherwise you just see a lot of
um violence and anger either over the
internet or when you see people at
rallies um
i think it's healthy for people to to
talk and discuss about it and maybe you
meet in the middle maybe you don't maybe
you still continue to disagree but um
yeah and i think that's life right like
we're never gonna agree on everything
and we also this is a massive a massive
topic that's very historical and it's
interwoven with a lot of other stuff
white supremacy misogyny
so um yeah i mean i think it's a massive
topic that you're never going to break
down in a single podcast but i think
it's important that we
facilitate those conversations
nonetheless so thank you for having me
yeah thanks for coming
um my name is yasmin um you can find me
on instagram um i am yazzy.x
um
[Music]
yeah i just put over why
um no i just really want to commend all
of us for being so mature about like
this topic it's not an easy topic to
talk about and it's not an easy topic to
share ideologies and actually respect
them so um there could be times where
people would just don't give a [ __ ]
about each other's
opinions or views and i really do think
that everyone took in the time to
appreciate everyone's um
opinion so
yeah
yeah i kind of enjoyed listening to
everyone's like
how they express their opinions and how
they like draw rational arguments for
things that's why i like being on the
show so
a bit congrats to pearl to let me on the
show all the time and um give it more
super chats because she's like wrapping
these super chats and she's reading them
so fast like a big congrats to pearl
yeah
yeah yeah
he'd has no learning difficulties
with intellectual development
we'll teach him how to read faster
appreciate that yeah yeah i don't know
what was there
okay um okay two more super chats up at
the end
what is it eight dollar sign fifty i
don't know if this is fifty dollars like
there's an a in front of it what is it
isn't that like another country yeah
wait let me see it's like that could be
australian dollar yeah maybe extremely
okay well no but that would be old
see
i don't i don't know what it is but
anyone who steps up to defend their
opinions even if even if they're wrong
should be
congratulated
i agree i agree um okay then the next
one is pita pita 21 weeks and five days
is the earliest a baby has been born and
survived is 21 weeks in five days um i
think that's the last one okay perfect
well guys thank you so so much oh my
gosh thank you
um for real um you got like seriously
all of the super chats are going towards
new equipment you guys have seen the new
ups in the studio um we just hired a
producer and honestly none of these
updates would be possible without all
the super chats that you guys have sent
so i really really appreciate it thank
you so much
um don't forget to subscribe to the
channel seriously like this video on
your way out it helps with the algorithm
and i'll talk to